bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à la veille
de l'ouverture du nouveau volet
2014-2020 de la politique de cohésion
européenne les sénateurs UMP ont
organisé le 19 février en présence de
Stéphane Lefol le ministre de
l'Agriculture un débat sur les nouveaux
défis du monde rural il fait suite à la
publication récente d'un rapport sur
l'avenir des campagnes le milieu rural
c'est en effet 80 % des territoires pour
20 % de la population mais aujourd'hui
de nouvelles populations s'y installent
du coup il faut redéfinir le mode de
gouvernance pour traiter d'égal à égal
tous les territoires l'urbain comme le
rural car la ruralité s'appuie encore
aujourd'hui sur les cantons et les
communes alors même qu'elles ne sont
plus en mesure de répondre aux besoins
d'aménagement c'est d'ailleurs une
préoccupation constante de la chambre
représentant les collectivité
territoriale qui est le Sénat mais tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle pour
revoir ce débat sur les nouveaux défis
du monde rural très bonne matinée à tous
sur Public
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur les nouveaux défis du monde
rural la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe GR qui a demandé ce
débat à savoir le groupe
UMP monsieur Gérard bailli pour le
groupe donc union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
bonjour monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais tout d'abord vous dire combien
je suis heureux d'intervenir dans ce
débat sur les nouveaux défis du monde
rural demandés par le groupe pump et qui
a reçu l'accord de la Conférence des
Présidents 2h30 d'échanges seront
consacrés à ce sujet qui concerne mes
chers collègues 80 % du territoire de
notre pays car la France demeure un
espace essentiellement rural maillet par
près de 30000 communes rurales au sens
de l'INC qui représente 78 % du
territoire métropolitain et 22 % de la
population par-dà de la diversité des
campagnes françaises et des configuré
locale les multiples dynamiques en œuvre
dans les aires rurales ont fini par
inverser les flux de population après
plus d'un siècle d'exode rural le solde
migratoire dans les campagnes est devenu
positif à la fin des années 70 c'est là
sans doute un motif de satisfaction pour
qui redoutait il y a quelques décennies
encore une tendance irrésistible à la
désertification d'une portion majeure de
notre territoire mais aujourd'hui i la
crise et son cortège de fermeture
d'entreprisees des PME des PMI des
exploitations agricoles pose la question
cruciale de la résilience des économies
rurales sur le terrain ce sont beaucoup
d'interrogations et difficultés tendent
à se multiplier avec de nouvell fractur
social et générationnelle même si les
réalités sont toujours très contrastées
d'un territoire à l'autre vous le savez
tous le contexte général apparaît plus
mouvant et incertain que jamais à à
regarder de près les opportunités sont
bien plus rares que les menaces les
menaces à
justement voire diminution accélérée des
finances publiques étiolement du premier
pilier de la PAC renforcement des
contraintes énergétique péréurbanisation
rampante besoin croissant de mobilité
exigen environnemental accru éloignement
despôles de décision en sans quelques
menace de pareil inventaire il convient
de ne pas céder au découragement ni
davantage à une quelconque rêverie
d'inspiration technicienne il faut avec
lucidité identifier les leviers
structurels qui conditionneront les sort
économique social et culturel des
campagnes que faire pour leur donner les
moyens de s'inscrire au cours des trois
prochaines décennies dans un scénario
que je pense vous souhaitez tous un
scénario de développement optimal la
capacité de projection imagination et la
créavité des acteurs territoriaux dont
nous sommes témoins seront fondamentales
pour saisir de nouvelles opportunités à
identifier de nouveaux leviers de
développement pour les territoires
ruraux comprenons bien chers collègues
que les campagnes dans leur diversité ne
sont pas une charge mais une chance pour
la France voyez ces vastes espaces cette
nature fragile mais généreuse la variété
de ses paysages et de ses cultures voyez
encore ces hommes bien décidés à innover
et à se battre pour faire vivre leur
territoire en y exerçant les activités
les plus variées traditionnelles et
d'avant-garde notre potentiel de
croissance est en gestation dans le
creuset de nos campagnes protégeons ce
laboratoire qui s'invente la modernité
de demain mais ces territoires ne
peuvent plus être pensés indépendamment
des villes avec lesquelles ils
entretiennent le rapport de
complémentarité et de dépendance
réciproque quelques mots sur l'état des
lieux en 2010 les surfaces agricoles
cultivées ou en herbes représentent 51 %
de l'espace métropolitain les espaces
naturels les bois les sols boisés les
Landes les sols nus zones humides en
représentent pratiquement 40 % et je
dirais les sols artificialisés les sols
bâtis les sols revêous stabilisés à peu
près 9
%. quelles sont les évolutions récentes
l'artificialisation des sols s'est
accélérée vous le savez en entre 2003 et
2009 affectant l'équivalent d'un
département français moyen 6100 km² en 7
ans contre la même surface en 10 ans
entre 92 et 2003 sur une période de 5
ans de 2006 à 2010 la surface des sols
artificialisés a progressé pratiquement
de 7 % au détriment des terres agricoles
dont il est avéré que plus d'un tiers
était de très bonne qualité agronomique
cette artificialisation a pris s
pasalement eu lieu bien sûr à l'approche
des zones urbaines la forêt a gagné de
l'espace non seulement sur les landes et
les friches mais encore de façon
marginale sur les terres agricoles avec
une progression notable en montagne et
dans les zones rurales profondes en y
étraînant parfois une fermeture des
paysages comme vous le voyez chers
collègues nous trouvons différentes
diversités dans nos territoires ruraux
les campagnes très agricoles de bonne
productivité où les agriculteurs et les
professions qui les entourent sont
d'au-delà de 10 % de la population les
campagnes qu de ville plus de vie plutôt
résidentiels où sont venus habiter les
citadins que l'on trouve plus
particulièrement dans les zones de 30 km
autour des grandes agglomérations les
campagnes mixtes où l'activité agricole
industrielle et résidentielle sont
estimées à 10500 communes avec 5
millions et demi d'habitants sur 140000
km² mais aussi malheureusement les
campagne vieilli à faible densité
représentant 5200000 habitants sur 12800
communes et 227000 k m² tout ça sont des
chiffres de l'gc dans un environnement
ces dernières fortement rural souvent
difficile d'accès sur lequel les grandes
métropoles n'exercent que peu
d'influence mais le monde rural a des
défis à relever il doit croire en ses
chances c'est déjà ce que nous avons pu
constater ces dernières décennies mais
faut-il que ces projets son dynamisme
ses ambitions soient accompagnées par
l'État les différentes collectivités
territorial les
institutions et je vais citer et je vais
citer quelques et je vais et je vais
citer quelques-uns de ces leviers
premier levier pour que je pense c'est
l'intercommunalité je crois que nous
pouvons constater que l'intercommunalité
a été très bénéfique pour tous les
territoires mais plus encore dans les
territoires ruraux qui par l'Union je
dirais par l'unisson de leur communes
ont réalisé ces dernières années des
équipements favorables à leur population
et qui n'existait pas jusqu'alors nous
pouvons prendre en exemple et cela en
désordre les foyers logements les
crèches les centres de loisirs sans
hébergement les terrains de sport des
médiathèques des zones artisanales
industrielles des gestions de patrimoine
classés des emplois à caractères
environnementaux groupes scolaires des
maisons de santé mais aussi
d'équipements pour les nouvelles
technologie mais tout cela en coûte tout
cela a des coûtes est souvent plus élevé
dès qu'on parle de réseaux de terrains
rocheux dans les dans les secteurs
ruraux de distance et plus encore vous
le savez chers collègues en zone de
montagne pour des projets plus ambitieux
encore pour demain je crois qu'il faudra
que nous facilitions toutes les
procédures afin de faciliter les actions
entre
intercommunalités quelques mots sur les
normes dans l'avenir l'intercommunalité
doit peut-être sous toutes ses formes
accompagné mais vu les particularités
les différences de situation il ne peut
pas y avoir y avoir les mêmes exigences
identiques dans la gouvernance dans
toutes les normes nombre d'élèves dans
pour une classe distance d'un équipement
minimum pour un tel structure de
population exemple des pharmacies ou
même pour des recettes buralistes qui
sont souvent rappelé et vous le savez
tous par les maires que nous côtoyons
par nos élus locaux c'est pourquoi nous
nous devons laisser davantage
d'initiatives lorsque celles-ci ont reçu
un consensus sur le territoire bien sûr
en respectant les lois de la République
mais qui par contre doivent tenir compte
de ces toutes ces particularités de ces
différences je vais maintenant évoquer
les dotations accompagner ces
territoires c'est aussi apportter les
mêmes dooptations aux communes aux
communautés de communes que celles que
reçoivent les villes hier avant
l'intercommunalité il est vrai que les
villes les gros bourgs investissaient
souvent dans les réalisations qui
étaient utilisées par les eurau venant à
la ville mais aujourd'hui la majeure
partie de ces équipements et leur
fonctionnement sont à la rechge des
structure intercommunale et chaque
habitant sur chaque parcelle du
territoire participe à la à la même
hauteur et je dirais il en est bien ASI
il en est bien ainsi mais comment
comprendre ces écarts de DGF
l'association des mares ruraux indique
que la DGF devient unique 128 € dans les
communes de plus de 150000 habitants
alors que les communes de moins de 3500
habitants percevaient entre 64 et 88 €
par habitant il en est de même pour les
structures intercommunales entre les
dotations aux agglomérations et les
communautés de communes en Milie rural
qui qui
augmente encore considérablement ces
chiffres et oui chers collègues sur ces
quelques données chiffrées on peut
s'appuyer pour justifier de tel sur ces
quelques données comment s'appuyer pour
justifier de tels chiffres deel écarts
ou alors chers collègues je n'ose le
penser est-ce que c ces décisions
n'appartiennent qu'aux citadins je n'ose
le
croire je parlerai maintenant quelques
mots de la représentativité cela m'amène
à évoquer la gouvernance et la
représentativité des territoires et je
citerai un titre de journal que vous
connaissez tous bien chers collègues
l'hémicycle du 13 février donc il est
tout
récent le grand le titre disait un
redécoupage des cantons qui maltraitent
les territoires ruraux et j'ai pu lire
et j'ai pu lire encore j'ai pu lire
encore et j'ai pe lire encore la taille
des cantons
ruraux la
taille la taille des
cantons laissz monsieur oui oui monsieur
G allez laissez parler l'orateur s'il
vous plaît j'ai pu lire encore la taille
des cantons ruraux peu peupl va croître
et se délater c'est toujours l'hémicycle
qui parle que restera-t-il de la
proximité dans d'immense canton ruraux
peu peuplé sans d'identité géographique
ni historique ce sont nos chaînes que
l'on abat c'est dit dans l'hémicycle
vous chers collègues qui habitez dans
ces territoires je crois que vous êtes
un certain nombre vous le savez il y
aura moins de porte-parole moins de
porte-voix moins de défenseur de la
ruralité dans nos assemblées
départementales même si je comprends
qu'il fallait réduire les écarts de
population mais par mais par contre
tenir compte aussi de la superficie que
gérera demain un conseiller
départemental et j'aimerais monsieur le
ministre avoir votre sentiment sur ce
point de
vuel chers collègues je voudrais
quelques mots sur l'environnement les
nouveaux défis des territoires ruraux
sont nombreux elles pourront être
accomplis aux conditions que je viens de
citer et que je vais encore évoquer ils
doivent conserver la qualité de leur
environnement pour les habitants
eux-mêmes mais aussi pour les cit qui
viennent se ressourcer il faut conserver
la qualité des EAU des nappes qui
alimentent ne l'oublion pas aussi les
villes et pour cela réaliser
l'assignissement collectif ou individuel
de chaque bourg de chaque village je
dirais presque de chaque maison et cela
a pour eux un cout non négligeable ce
sont aussi les espaces ruraux qui
accueillent les résidus des déchets des
stations d'épuration des grandes
collectivités qu'il faudra aussi traiter
à
bontion je crois que les terres
aussi un atout ce sont les énergies je
ne veux pas pour passer sous silence le
rôle in importance que joue et joueront
encore d'avantage les espaces ruraux
producteurs d'énergie c'est là où on y
installe les éoliennes c'est là où on
installe le solaire qu'on peut y faire
aussi des production de biomasse de bois
de bois énergie mais aussi les
biocarburants c'est une richesse pour
notre pays notre pays comme sur ces
territoires mais ces territoires ne pe
bien ne pourront vivre que bien entendu
s'il y a désenclavement désenclavement
d'abord des nouvelles technologies ces
territoires devront faire face à la
fructure fracture numérique plus
qu'ailleurs vu l'éloignement toutes les
entreprises mais aussi tous les
habitants veulent et voudront le haut
débit voire le très haut débit et si
aujourd'hui les opérateurs vont équiper
les agglomérations importantes vous le
savez il n est pas de même pour les
petites collectivités et les grands
espaces ruraux mais une question qui pai
c'est une charge importante supportée
par les assemblées de séries
territoirees donc des habitants au
niveau des communes des
intercommunalités des départements on
sait qu'on demande une péquation
nationale elle est attendue mais elle
peine à se mettre en place c'est un défi
important du monde reural à relever mais
il ne pourra naturellement il ne pourra
pas le faire seul le désenclavement
routier ferroviaire est un gage de
vitalité le ferroviaire est peu présent
dans le monde rural il n'y aura que bien
peu d'alternative entre le bus quand il
existe et la route mais faudra-t-il que
les conseillers généraux départementaux
deain puissent continuer à améliorer les
réseaux routiers et leur apporter les
entretiens nécessaires une PME une PMI
ne s'installera pas sur un territoire si
le désenclavement physique et pour un
par un accès rapide et le désenclavement
numérique ne sont pas au rendez-vous ça
aussi c'est un très grand défi pour la
ruralité quelques mots sur l'éducation
les territoires ruraux ne dev devont pas
être les parents pauvres du système
éducatif ils devront pouvoir disposer de
CFA lycées professionnels ou antennes
universitaire dans des périmètres pas
trop éloignés il faut donner à tous nos
jeunes ruraux des ambitions scolaires et
ce dès l'école primairire qui doit
rester bien réparti sur les territoires
ruraux afin qu' qu'unlè ne passe pas
plus de 30 à 40 minutes matins et soir
dans un
bus aussi très important vous le savez
tous la santé une devront pas être non
plus les parents pauvres des équipements
de santé la présence de médecins doit
être encouragée en proposant des mesures
incitative en réalisant des maisons de
santé et pourquoi pas dans certains cas
avoir recours au salariat voire à des
mesures correxcitives un maillage des
urgences médicales et des pharmacies
mais aussi des gardes j'ai entendu ce
matin notre collègue Guillaume qui
parlait des gardes dans le M rural qui
n'existe plus mais aussi des gardes par
sont inexistantes et tout ça quand même
on ne peut pe pas l'accepter mais il
faudra bien aussi différencier les
critères entre les secteurs urbains ou
là encore dans le milieu rural des temps
de parcours doivent rester
raisonnables la population des campagnes
vous le savez est plus âgée que dans les
grandes agglomérations c'est pourquoi il
doit y avoir un nombre suffisant de
foyers logement d'pad avec des normes
adaptées afin de répondre à la proximité
attendue des résidents et de leur
familles n'oubliez pas chers collègues
que la présence médicale comme la
présence scolaire sont sans doute les
exigences premières que souhaitent les
ruraux mais aussi les nouveaux résidents
de ces
territoire ces préalables étant
accomplis ou existant c'est préalable en
matière de gouvernance de désenclavement
de servicees de qualité d'environnement
d'accompagnement financier peut-on être
optimiste pour ces territoires ruraux je
réponds oui car c'est alors que l'on
peut espérer espérer la venue de
résidents qui iront travailler à la
ville si elle n'est pas pas trop
distante espérer que des entreprises de
production puissent s'y installer ou se
développer car vous le savez tous il y a
tant de savoir-faire et de production
locale à
encourager je parlerai d'abord de la
production agricole la France ce grand
pays agricole son pétrole vert comme l'a
dit un chef d'État est un atout par ses
quantités mais aussi par la renommé à
l'international de ses productions son
bétail ses vins alcool ses fromages et
vous le savez monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture production agricole qui
procure tant d'emplois dans les
entreprises de l'agroalimentaire on a pu
l'actualité malheureusement nous le
rappelle production alimentaire dans
nombreux territoires que serait la
Bretagne sans ces productions agricoles
la valorisation des produits agricoles
doit être le souci permanent des
dirigeants face à cette compétition qui
est devenue mondiale qui atteint aussi
les production agricole AOC label
circuit court doivent être encouragés et
facilités dans leur mise en marché avec
les collectivités l'élevage est aussi
indispensable sur nos nombreux
territoires surtout là où la charrue ne
peut pas remplacer l'animal sur les
pâures les pendes de nos montagnes avec
des surfaces immenses mais attention la
baisse des effectifs de nos beau vins
est déjà bien réel comme l' est encore
davantage la baisse drastique et
continue de nos effectifs au vin chers
collègues je vous rappellerai deux
chiffres en
1980 notre élevage auovin c'était
12800000 têtres en 2012 il n'est plus
que de 7600000 têtres d'où de nombreuses
importations avec des prix peu
rénumérateurs et qu'encore excusez-moi
de le dire et qu'encore la présence de
prédateurs protégés par les ministre de
l'Environnement successif vient
décourager lesleveur de nos
massifs attention monsieur le ministre
attention monsieur le ministre que la
réforme de la pque sur laquelle je sais
que vous vous battez dans son premier
pilier ne doit pas mise à mal par les
décisions européennes sur l'élevage je
gage d'un environnement principalement
protégé dans nos campagnes et soit
accompagné à sa juste valeur mais aussi
à sa juste
rénumération je crois vraiment que
l'agriculture peut jouer encore demain
un grand rôle dans la vitalité de nos
territoires ruraux avec l'entretien des
paysages avec son poids économique et
avec l'importance des emploi pour la
transformation dans nos entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire et elle peut encore
rester le pétrole vert de notre pays
chers collègues notre planète s'agrandit
chaque jour et c'est un chiffre qui m'a
fait vraiment
beaucoup
d'attention chaque jour de 200000
humains alors ne gâchons pas nos terres
productive il y a tant d'espace de sol
peu productifs où l'on peut urbaniser
pour continuer le développement de de
notre pays mais faut-il que cette motion
Terra faible productivité entre dans les
objectifs des les documents d'urbanisme
notre agriculture ne pourra pas
supporter longtemps la méconnaissance et
la concurrence des OGM mais loin de moi
l'idée d'autoriser les OGM les OGM sans
une certitude sans une certitude de leur
non dangerosité c'est pourquoi Monsieur
le Ministre j'ai attiré dernièrement
votre attention au cours d'une question
orale sur ce besoin significatif d'étude
de suivi mise en place en conjuguant nos
moyens au niveau
européen
véritable richesse de nos territoires
ruraux nos forêts mais aussi le bois de
nos bocages de Noë qu'il faut davantage
utiliser mieux valorisé nos grumes qui
prennent malheureusement le chemin
d'autres pays pour leur transformation
et reviennent ensuite alors que la
valeur ajoutée à les emplois sont perdu
pour notre pays là aussi un vrai défi à
relever mais comment aussi rivaliser
avec l'avancée technologique des pays de
l'Europe du Nord qui permet de
concurrencer sur notre territoire
l'utilisation de nos résineux même si le
bois énergi granulé ou déchiqueté
connaît un développement significatif
des progrès et des possibilités peuvent
encore être dans ce domaine-elà très
important la forêt la filière bois
apporte vous le savez de l'emploi sur
nos territoires ruraux emplois locaux
dans nos villages pour l'entretien des
forêts pour l'abattage le débardage la
transformation du bois et mérite une
attention sans doute encore plus
particulière pour une meilleure valeur
tion et le développement de l'emploi
n'oublions pas d'investir dans la dans
les plantations on plante plus beaucoup
dans ce pays comme l'on fait nos
ancêtres n'oublions pas non plus les
dessertes forestières par les actions
des ASAS elles sont indispensables pour
les prélèvements forestiers et surtout
je dirais une meilleure cultive d'bois
pour nos territoires ruraux vous savez
aussi combien compte le tourisme les TER
ruraux ont essayé de relever ces
dernières décennies les défis du
tourisme avec des réussites variées
suivant les atouts locaux mais aussi la
détermination des acteurs touristiques
et l'accompagnement de leur collectivité
emploi non délocalisable investissement
productif pour les entreprises locales
de travaux publics d'artisan du bâtiment
et client du commerce local
la 3 minutes président bah oui mais vous
aviez 20 minutes pourtant je vais vite
hein l'activité touristique a
déterminant même sur les périodes
courtes elle apporte une vitalité
supplémentaire à nos territoires ruraux
et comme je l'ai déjà évoqué
nécessairire pour nos services de
proximité nos commerces nos artisans le
les touristes comme les résidents savent
apprécier les manifestation culturelles
sportifes fites de pays marchés locaux
qui sont importants et capital et qui
sont souvent réalisés avec dévouement
par les bénévoles sur ces territoires
ces bénévoles ce sont des atouts
indéiables de vraie valeur veillons à ce
que cette flamme ne faiblisse pas elle
aurait des conséquences graves je sais
aussi l'importance de toutes nos PME nos
PMI véritable richesse de nos
territoires ruraux ce sont ces petites
et moyennes entreprises qui procurent du
travail de proximité au population
active locale elle fixe à proximité les
habitants qui décident de rester et de
vivre parfois loin des grandes métropole
ce sont des facteurs de croissance
facteurs d'image facteurs d'équilibre
des territoires il doit y avoir un souci
permanent de leur apporter des moyens de
poursuivre ici leur activité je pense
plus particulièrement au désenclavements
numérique que j'ai déjà cité un
accompagnement de mesures fiscales doit
être poursuivi pour plus
particulièrement dans les zones de
révéidation orale et la montagne terminé
monsieur et bien je vais dire la
conclusion et je vais sauter ce que mon
paragraphe encore sur les
PME ma conclusion je suis consciant
chers collègues que je n'ai pas abordé
tous les sujets
tous les nouveaux défis à relever dans
le monde rural mais je sais que d'autres
collègues vont intervenir ajouter
d'autres idées et arguments permettant
de définir des priorités des actions
indispensables comme je viens de le
faire afin que ces territoires ne soient
pas victimes de la rareté des crédits
publics de la faiblesse des
investissements notamment du bérique et
du désenclavement comme vous le savez ce
sont souvent les plus petits qui
disparaissent et sont plus plus
fragilisés d'où la vigilance que j'ai
rappelé à plusieurs reprises dans mes
propos le gouvernement actuel en son
sein une ministre chargé de l'égalité
des territoires je pense que madame la
ministre aura une veille permanente sur
les territoires ruraux et plus
particulièrement encore sur les
campagnes éloignées des grandes
métropoles mais sur l'égalité fiscale
éducative sanitaire que j'ai évoqué j'ai
foi dans ces territoires car l'élection
après élection vous le savez chers
colollèges termine Monsieur B il y a des
hommes de tout bord qui se battent et se
dépensent sans compter pour chacune des
parcelles de leur pays de leur secteur
économique pour chacune de leur
production mais pour se battre il faut
des armes des armes égales apporté par
la solidarité européenne et nationale
monsieur ministre monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues le Parlement doit
aussi être vigilant plus encore à ces
temps pour relever ses
décis je vais aller tout de suite à la
toute toute conclusion vous voyez oui
monsieur J'ai fois en toutes C
possibilités que pourra apporter la
ruralité à notre pays et que je viens de
rappeler je pense que demain plus encore
qu' qu'hier davantage encore
qu'aujourd'hui les habitants de nos
métropoles de nos grandes agglomérations
auront besoin de ces espaces pour se
détendre pour se distraire se reposer
que chacun dans ce bill comprenne la
complémentarité ville campagne c'est mon
vu le plus cher que nos territoires
ruraux et foi dans leur avenir et comme
l'a dit le général de De Gaulle la fin
de l'espoir c'est le commencement de la
mort
merci bien merci
monsieur
mes chers collègues il y a un autre
débat à
17h aussi important qui sera d'ailleurs
présidé par notre Président je vous
demande de respecter les temps de parole
qui ont été décidés par vos groupes à la
conférence des des présidents parce que
sinon on sera forcé d'ouvrir une séance
ce soir de nuit voilà s'il vous plaît je
fais je fais appel à votre intelligence
et je suis persuadé que vous allez
répondre en ce sens dans la suite du
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard Larcher
vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues ce débat
sur le nouveaux défi du monde rural
demandé par notre groupe est important
il intervient quelques jours après
l'accord des chefs d'État et
gouvernement sur le le cadre financier
pluriannuel de l'Union européenne qui
d'ailleurs marque une diminution globale
et progressive des crédits consacré à la
politique agricole commune - 13 % qui
devrait impacter la France pour 3 %.
alors que s'ouvre cette semaine le Salon
de l'Agriculture on doit s'interroger
sur le sens profond sur cette évolution
sur les défis généraux que doit relever
le monde rural et ne pas oublier qu'il
n'y a pas d'avenir pour reprendre le
titre du rapport de Gérard bailli et
roderico les qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir
pour les campagnes sans une agriculture
performante et j'y
reviendrai sans une agriculture
performante et de qualité elle façonne
d'ailleurs les paysages les rend
attractifs sans une gouvernance qui n'en
fasse pas des territoires supplétif sans
un engagement volontariste qui l'équipe
j'utilise le terme monde rural car c'est
bien ce qui caractérise la ruralité
d'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un ensemble
homogène comme le note trs bien le
rapport de nos deux collègues certains
territoires ruraux attirent et se
développent notamment certaines zones
périurbaines mais aussi les parties
littorales et l'éliotropisme jouent un
rôle important mais un certain nombre
d'autres continuent de décliner et
renontent de réelles difficultés
notamment lié à l'enclavement
géographique mais aussi technologique
l'enclavement technologique
indispensable au développement du
maillage notamment des petites et des
moyennes entreprises sur ce territoire
je me rappelle en cela de nombreux
débats que nous avons eu ici sur l'accès
au haut débit et au très haut débit
indispensable au développement de ces
territoires ces territoires
d'ailleurs les plus fragiles sont
souvent des territoires consacrés à
l'élevage qui occupe 50 % de la 55 % des
exploitations et une majorité du
territoire agricole y aurait-il pour
certains de ces territoires une fatalité
un inexorable déclin alors trois
condition me paraissent devoir
être considéré comme essentiel pour
relever ces défis tout d'abord la
gouvernance de ces territoires et
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est bien la question de la gouvernance
de ces territoires qui est posé parce
que n'en doutons pas un certain nombre
de réformes qui nous est proposé ici
vont conduire à ce que ces territoires
ne soient plus représentés et c'est un
élu urbain et pri urbain qui vous le dit
ici que de manière marginale que de
manière marginale et
pardonnez-moi si je prends un
département comme le gare quand le
territoire des séevenines ne sera plus
représenté que par un très grand canton
alors que l'ensemble de la
représentation se fera le long de la
côte et bien croyez-vous que le
territoire rural Pera d'un quelconque
poids dans la décision politique je
crois que nous assemblé des territoire
nous sommes l'assemblée de la correction
des zones pauvres en démographie mais
qui ont besoin d'un avenir c'est le sens
profond du Sénat qui n'est pas l'OM de
l'Assemblée nationale et je crois comme
élu urbain d'un territoire d'1400000
habitants pouvoir le dire c'est la
responsabilité que nous avons ici me
semble-t-il de manière particulière au
Sénat mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues l'annonce
de la diminution des dotations de l'État
aux collectivités
territoriales pèsera pèsera beaucoup
moins sur la commune de Rambouillet que
sur les communes voisines du Sud iveline
ou de l'uréloire où les dotations de
l'État c'est 50 % du budget de
fonctionnement de ces communes et
naturellement si nous ne sommes pas très
attentifs à ces communes à ces
intercommunalités rural n'en doutez pas
au-delà de la répartition des pouvoirs
c'est l'avenir même de ces territoires
de leur vitalité qui sera posé voilà
pourquoi je voulais poser très
clairement dans la responsabilité qui
est la mienne la question essentielle de
la gouvernance du territoire rural sinon
nos débats n'auront été que des blablas
sucessif et le territoire rural sera
progressivement gommé au bénéfice des
territoires urbains ce qui veut dire
qu'il ne faut pas opposer territoire
rural et territoire urbain bien au
contraire le territoire rural a besoin
d'être relié aux villes et ce lien avec
les villes est tout à fait essentiel et
les villes ne doivent pas considérer le
territoire rural uniquement comme un
lieu de recréation ou d'espace mais
comme un élément majeur du développement
économique du pays monsieur le ministre
vous êtes sans doute le ministre qui
porte un des rares excédents budgétaires
de notre pays un des rares excédents
budgéires en tous les cas en
matière de commerce extérieur avec une
année qui s'annonce plutôt bonne ça veut
dire que le troisè des éléments au-delà
de l'aménagement du territoire c'est
d'avoir une agriculture performante une
agriculture qui produise et faisons
attention dans un certain nombre de
décisions notamment concernant les
normes concernant un certain nombre de
regards qu'on porte sur le territoire de
ne pas faire de l'agriculture
d'aujourd'hui et de demain la cidérurgie
d'hier je crois qu'il nous faut être
particulièrement attentif à ce sujet si
je prends un exemple qui peut sembler
microscopique mais qui serassemble
sensible au
breton quand on voit la décision sur les
normes lié au bien-être animal et c'est
un vétérinaire qui vous dit que le
bien-être animal c'est quelque chose
d'important sur les poules pondeuses ce
à quoi nous assistons c'est 9000
exploitations consacré à la poule
pondeuse il vont en disparaître 20 % par
l'incapacité financière tout simplement
de ces élevages à s'adapter à
l'application brutale d'une norme et
au-delà de cela nous voyons la
croissance des prix pour le consommateur
et nous allons exporter sans
traçabilité un certain nombre de
production avicole et production de de
pays extérieur on marche un peu sur la
tête je dois dire que la fragilité des
filières et on le voit au combien en ce
moment combien elle est sensible et puis
il y a la question du revenu agricole
les ivelines c'est naturellement peu un
territoire agricole mais le svelin c'est
un territoire céréalier je me réjouis du
revenu des céréaliers aujourd'hui mais
quand je vois que le revenu des éleveurs
du Perche tout proche du mien et plus de
la moitié moins que que celle des
séréaliers quand je vois que pour les
éleveurs de bovin c'est encore 10000 €
de moins quand je vois que pour les
maréché où vous avez supprimé
l'exonération partielle du travail
notamment de ceux qui viennent aider à
la récolte et bien nous nous disons que
aujourd'hui vous avez pris des décisions
contre la compétitivité de l'agriculture
française alors monsieur le ministre à
un moment où nous devons installer des
jeunes agricul je constate simplement
que le choix qui a été fait c'est de
baisser largement et le rapport de notre
collègue César le montrer les dotation à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
en fait le territoire rural est une
chance pour la France et c'est un défi
que nous devons gagner ce qu' tracé
Gérard bailli c'est bien ce défi là je
voulais vous dire queun nouvelle
agriculture intégrée qui soit à la fois
orienté vers des circuits courts vers
des labels des IGP mais qui soit aussi
une force export atrice car le monde
demain aura besoin de l'Europe pour se
nourrir ne l'oublions pas chassons ces
clichés d'une agriculture qui ne serait
qu'un aménagement du territoire ou de
son paysage nous avons besoin de cette
nouvelle agriculture je n'oublie pas
comme ancien ministre du Travail que
l'industrie agroalimentaire c'est un des
rares secteurs où nous avons évité la
désindustrialisation et que cette
réalité là nous devons la prendre en
compte voilà pourquoi ces défis monsieur
le ministre me semble passer par une
autre politique de gouvernance des
territoires c'est-à-dire de choix
j'allais dire de représentation de ces
territoire d' politique volontariste
d'aménagement du territoire et je le dis
très très clairement d'un soutien à ce
que représente l'agriculture et la
filière agroalimentaire et notamment les
productions animales dans les temps qui
viennent je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
l'archer dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Madame René
niou bonjour
bonjour monsieur le Président messieur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
moi aussi je me félicite que le monde
rural soit misise à l'honneur
aujourd'hui devant notre assemblée et
prenne et que nous prenions le temps de
débattre de son
avenir la question qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui est aussi vaste que complexe
aussi cruciale que d'actualité il y a
quelques semaines comme l'a dit mon
collègue Gérard bli nous avons présenté
un rapport sur l'avenir des campagnes
dans le cadre de la délégation à la
prospective du Sénat et si nous avons
présenté ensemble ce rapport il n'en est
pas moins vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
pouvons voir quelques différence dans la
manière de
l'interpréter pour envisager cet avenir
il a fallu dresser un état des lieux il
est alarmant ce constat nous a conduit à
un scénario d'évolution de nos
territoires ruraux inaccepable qui
conduirait si rien n'est fait pour si
rien n'est fait pour l'inversé à
sacrifier purement et simplement nos
campagnes cette situation est d'autant
plus inquiétante qu'elle est paradoxale
en effet alors même que le dynamme
démographique des territoires ruraux est
avéré depuis près de 30 ans avec un
nouvel exode urbain que les Français
aspirent de plus en plus à s'y installé
que les innovations techniques sociales
et économiques qui sont de plus en plus
intéressantes alors même que beaucoup
ont enfin pris conscience que les
territoires ruraux sont avant tout une
chance pour la France et non une charge
le risque de les voir définitivement
transformé en espace de rélégation n'a
jamais été aussi
fort nous sommes aujourd'hui un tournant
majeur pour ces territoires le contexte
économique politique et social actuel
augure des changements sociétaux profond
qui impacteront dans les prochaines
années nos modes de vie si les
territoires ruraux ne prennent pas leur
place pleine et entière dans les
réformes qui seront inévitablement
menées ils seront condamnés or les défis
sont nombreux l'agriculture cela cela a
été dit par mes prédécesseurs même si la
présentation en était pas tout à fait la
même cultur traverse une crise certes
inégale selon les secteurs mais
néanmoins importante et durable le
détricotage de la pâac la concentration
des exploitations la régression des
surfaces agricoles le problème de
renouvellement des générations sont
autant de facteurs qui mettent à mal
notre modèle agricole et impactent la
vie et le paysage de nos territoires
ruraux même s'il ne faut pas que la
ruralité soit réduite à la seule place
de l'agriculture dans le monde rural
personne ne peut nier que ce secteur
d'activité est important et joue un rôle
primordial dans notre société par la
production d'alimentation et dans la
manière dont est façonner notre
environnement l'artificialisation des
sols se poursuit entre 2003 et
2009 il a affecté l'équivalent d'un
département ce qui n'est pas sans
conséquence pour l'aménagement du
territoire la qualité des paysages et le
maintien des activités agricole la crise
énergétique impacte profondément les
populations rurales le age urbain génère
des coûts supplémentaires en teres de
transport et d'énergie l'éloignement
croissant entre le lieu de travail et de
vie est de plus en plus contraignant
financièrement car si un Français sur 4
réside dans une commune rurale seul un
sur h y travaille la sociologie des
populations rurales peineent à se
diversifier et s'accompagne d'un
vieillissement global et d'un phénomène
inquiétant d'immigration de la pauvreté
urbaine vers les
campagnes les services publics de Proxim
se rarfie conséquence inévitable de la
révision générale des politiques
publiques ce qui oblige à des efforts de
mutualisation souvent difficile or sans
service public il n'y a ni attractivité
ni maintien des populations de la même
manière l'offre de santé se rétracte
dans les territoires les plus fragiles
le récent rapport sénatorial de notre
collègue le fichier sur la
désertification médicale y revient
longuement som et j'espère que vous
excuserez la noirceur du tableau qui que
je suis en train de dresser les
inégalités territoriales s'accroissent
et nous risquons d'arriver tôt ou tard à
un point de non
retour pour autant il n'est bien
évidemment pas trop tard sinon nous ne
serions pas là aujourd'hui pour en
discuter la situation est paradoxale car
malgré ces constats alarmants une réelle
prise de conscience du potentiel de nos
campagnes a eu lieu ces dernières années
des projets S souvent innovant
fleurissent portés par des acteurs
dynamiques et créatifs des
complémentarités se développent entre
les territoires des jeunes générations
viennent s'installer avec de véritables
projets de vie des filières agricoles
qualitatives et durables se développent
souvent porté là aussi par des jeunes
tous les ingrédients d'un développement
harmonieux de nos territoires existent
les graines sont en terre et c'est à
nous décideurs politiques et
législateurs de les aider à pousser nous
vrons déjà en ce sens dans nos
collectivités et il est désormais temps
de le faire au niveau national dans un
cadre législatif et réglementé
rénové dans le rapport que nous avons
présenté sur l'avenir des campagnes nous
identifions quatre leviers de croissance
majeurs indispensable à la mise en place
d'une véritable politique structurelle
de développement à long terme de toutes
nos campagnes dans leur diversité le
premier levier concerne la gouvernance
de nos territoires et donc la question
cruciale de l'organisation et du
pilotage des des politiques publiques la
réforme proposée se préoccupe de la
proximité nécessaire pour une meilleure
prise en compte de la ruralité et non
pas comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
éloignant la décision des des
territoires il est aujourd'hui
indispensable de renoué avec une
véritable politique d'aménagement du
territoire passant nécessairement par
une simplification des normes qui ne
sont pas récentes monsieur Larcher dont
l'extrême profusion pénalise lourdement
non seulement les entreprises mais aussi
les communes rurales
dépourvu de moyens pour les mettre en
œuvre d'autre part une véritable
politique nationale d'aide en ingénierie
territoriale est plus que jamais
nécessaire pour apporter un appui
technique aux élus locaux par ailleurs
il est indispensable de mener des
politiqu différencié en fonction des
réalités locales en tant qu'élu d'un
territoire dit de montagne j'insiste sur
ce point les spécificités géographique
ou démographique doivent être prises en
compte une application différencié de la
loi sur l'ensemble du pour une une
application différenciée de la loi sur
le
territoire si cela n'était pas le cas
nous assisterions à une plus forte
inégalité si l'on ne prend pas en compte
ni les coûts ni les temps de
transport finalement et c'est peut-être
ici le point le plus important cèg j'ai
coupé je j'ai j'ai de la marge notre
groupe a de la marge par rapport au
groupe précédent il y a eu 5 minutes
pour Monsieur pour mon prédécesseur pas
excusez-moi j'applique les décisions je
je souhaite terminer finalement et c'est
peut-être ici le point le plus important
il faut renforcer les politiques de
redistribution et de solidarité
nationale pour éviter que ne se forment
des poches de pauvreté dans les
territoires une meilleure répartition
des financements est essentielle tout
comme la mise en place effective d'une
véritable péréquation entre les
territoire deème levier identifier
l'accès aux services et aux équipements
publics le 3è levier concerne la
mobilité le désenclavement de nos
campagnes est indispensable pour leur
développement un accès satisfaisant au
réseau physique que ce soit pour les
entreprises et les populations ceci est
indispensable il faut donc sanctuariser
les financements nécessaires pour
l'entretien et le développement des
dessertes routières et ferroviaires le
4ème levier concerne l'accès au très
haut débit c'est une condition
syineéquanon de l'attractivité de nos
territoires c'est une nécessité à la
fois pour maintenir ou attirer des
entrepris en zone rurale et répondre à
une attente très forte de la population
de plus à l'heure où nous voulons
développer le télétravail la
télémédecine la téléformation
l'e-commerce il serait incompréhensible
d'exclure ceux qui par définition du
fait de leur isolement géographique
seraient les plus susceptibles d'y avoir
recours chacun le sait et je termine
là-dessus les défis qui attendent les
campagnes sont nombreux et de taille
l'un des principaux défis est celui des
moyens alors que les campagnes disposent
de nombreuses ressources des aménités
positives qui doivent être valorisé à la
hauteur des services rendus à l'ensemble
du pays au travers par exemple d'une
taxe spécifique comme la taxe carbone je
suis certaine que le dynamisme et le
volontarisme qui s'exprime chaque jour
dans nos territoires permettront de les
relever à condition de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement adapté je vous remercie
merci vous aviez 5 minutes vous avez
fait
alors on va dire que tout le monde est à
égalité ant je coupe alors dans la suite
du débat la parole est à Monsieur Gérard
Lecam monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
nouveaux défis du monde rural tel est
l'intitulé de ce débat sollicité après
la remise du rapport de la délégation de
la prospective par les sénateur René
niikou et Gérard ba je tiens ici à
saluer la qualité de leurs travaux
cependant et de primeabord permettez-moi
de constater que ce n'est mal
malheureusement pas la première fois que
nous échangeons sur ce thème le constat
est connu et même partagé sans que cela
nit permis d'évolution pour les
territoires ruraux cela n'est plus
acceptable alors que les majorités
gouvernementales et parlementaires ont
changé le 16 juin dernier nous attendons
au-delà de la création du ministère de
l'Égalité des territoire un véritable
changement qui soit réellement
profitable au territoires ruraux et à
leurs hab an en effet durant les
précédentes années où la droite était au
pouvoir les maîtres mot ont été ceux de
l'affaiblissement de l'action publique
et de la libéralisation du marché les
territoires ruraux ont été les premières
victimes de cette politique qui a
accentué la fracture sociale et
territorial plaçant les territoires en
concurrence les uns aux autres
assujettissant les politiques publiques
à l'ône de la rentabilité c'est donc
bien les conditions d'une nouvelle
politique pour la ruralité et même plus
largement pour les territoires qu'il
nous faut en envisager maintenant et en
urgence passer pour ainsi dire du
constat à l'action je voudrais ainsi
revenir sur les quatre leviers
identifiés par le
rapport je regrouperai ces leviers en
deux thématiques celle de la démocratie
au sein des territoires et celle des
services publics en terme de démocratie
au sein du groupe CRC nous avons
toujours nous avons soutenu lors de la
réforme des collectivités de 2010 et
nous continuons de soutenir le rôle
prépondérant des communes les 36000
communes de notre pays ne sont pas un
poids mais une richesse qui témoignent
de la diversité des territoires ainsi la
marche forcée des intercommunalités sous
l'égide des préfets nous semble être
incompatible avec les développements des
territoires ruraux puisque cela conduit
à une absorption par les villes centre
des communes plus petites
personnellement je défends l'idée qu'il
n'y a pas d'intercommunalité forte sans
communes fortes parallèlement les
politiques de pôle ont conduit à une
spécialisation des territoires et à une
concentration spati des richesses et des
investissements laissant sur le banc des
pans entiers du territoire loin de
remettre en cause ces logique la
préparation de l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation conforte cette démarche
d'ailleurs le rapport remis tout en
reconnaissant le rôle pivot de la
commune préconise l'élargissement de
certaines structures intercommunales et
des ensembles économiquement cohérents
pourtant une telle démarche contribue à
éloigner toujours plus les lieux de
décision des citoyens je feraiis
également remarquer à mes collègues que
ce qui doit fonder une intercommunalité
de projet ce n'est pas un un périmètre
économique pertinent mais le projet
politique partagé par les communes et
leurs élus nous demandons que les
communes et leurs représentants élus
soient respectés nous déplorons ainsi
que le débat sur la loi portant sur les
modes de scrutin n'est pas permis une
juste représentation des territoires
notamment ruraux garantissant à la fois
le respect de la parité et du pluralisme
concernant les dotations faites à ces
mêmes collectivités le processus engagé
organise l'asphyxie des communes aux
grand â de tous les élus locaux d'ici
2015 celle-ci devrait baisser de 3
milliards et ce alors même que ce sont
les collectivités qui supportent
majoritairement les dépenses
d'investissement porter atteinte au
volume des dotations constitue ainsi
très clairement un frein à l'essort de
tous les territoires y compris des
territoires ruraux par ailleurs nous
trouvons profondément anormal que les
dotations puissent varier du simple au
double entre les villes et les
territoires ruraux celles-ci doivent
être impérativement revalorisé nous
proposons donc que la nécessaire
taxation des actifs financier contribue
à revaloriser les dotations des communes
rurales en particulier mais aussi des
zones urbaines en difficulté cela
devrait être possible puisque la DGF
étant accordé par habitants cela ne
toucherait qu'un 5è de son volume global
on pourrait ainsi estimer de manière
purement comptable qu'avec 1 milliard
d'euros la situation pourrait se régler
et l'écart être résor b les
collectivités assument de plein fouet
les conséquences de la crise il n'est
pas opportun de les priver de ressources
par ailleurs alors que les transferts de
charges n'ont jamais été compensés la
réforme des rythmes scolaires va peser
une nouvelle fois lourdement sur les
budgets des communes cette démarche qui
alourdit les charges des communes sans
jamais les compenser contraint certaines
communes à réfléchir à de nouveaux
transferts de compétences aux
intercommunalités faute de pouvoir y
répondre par leur propre capacité
financière alors que les élus de la
nouvelle majorité défendaient il y a
encore quelques mois de nouveaux moyens
pour les collectivités et s'opposaient
au transfert de charg non compensé nous
appelons le gouvernement à revoir sa
copie pour que les élus des territoires
disposent enfin des moyens financiers
pour mettre en œuvre les politiques pour
lesquelles ils ont été élus concernant
la deuxième thématique celle des
services public je dois vous dire mes
chers collègues que je trouve amusant
que ce débat soit à l'initiative de nos
collègues du groupe UMP en effet nous
devons à l'ancienne majorité nombre de
lois ayant entériné la casse des
services publics organisant même ce que
certains ont pu qualifier le désert
français la politique d'aménagement du
territoire et de présence des services
publics c'est trop longtemps opérer à la
calculette sous l'angle de la
contraction de laction de l'État
notamment dans le cadre de la RGPP tout
domaine confondu je voudrais pour
commencer évoquer le plus emblématique
d'entre eux pour les territoires ruraux
jeux parler de la Poste l'ancien
gouvernement a privatisé cette
entreprise publique transformer des
bureaux de poste de plein exercice en
simple agence postale communal ou pire
encore en point de contact cette
politique a eu des conséquences
dramatiques dans les territoires
pourquoi alors que la majorité de gauche
était à nos côtés pour combattre cette
loi il y a quelques années les critères
de présence postal n'ont-ils pas été
modifiés depuis le mois de mai dernier
en effet aujourd'hui encore des points
sont attribués au bureau de poste en
fonction de l'importance de leur
activité passé en dessa de la barre des
30000 points le bureau se transforme en
agence postale communale et la descente
infernale s'engage nous demandons au
gouvernement que les critères
définissant la présence postale soient
adaptés aux réalités rurales dans le
cadre de la convention pensé entre
l'État la poste et l'Association des
maires de France il en est de même pour
l'hôpital la loi HPST que nous avons
combattu sur tous les bans de la gauche
a soumis ce service public aux règles de
la rentabilité opérant sous couvert de
rationalisation de l'offre a engagé la
fermeture d'hôpitaux en Ronald
territoire que ma collègue Annie David
connaît bien seul cinq territoir sur les
h départements ont été identifiés par
l'ARS l'hôpital de saintagrève en
Ardèche est menacé de fermeture parce
que le taux d'activité est jugé
insuffisant mes chers collègues pourquoi
prenez dans le même temps la création de
maisons de naissance qui n'offre pas les
mêmes conditions de sécurité qu'un
hôpital de plein exercice nous vous
engageons à réviser là encore les
critères de présence territorial et
organiser la refondte de la loi il en
est de même des seuils de fermeture de
classe en zon rural au-delà de la
création de 60000 postes que nous
soutenons totalement il faut là encore
sortir des logiques comptables et
permettre le maintien en zone rurale de
structures scolair de proximité le
rapport traite la présence des services
publics uniquement sous le temps de sous
l'angle du temps d'accès ce n'est pas
suffisant il faut aussi renforcer la
qualité même des services publics et la
formation de ces agents garant la
maîtrise nécessaire la nécessaire
maîtrise publique pour répondre
prioritairement à l'intérêt général et
pour ce qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
adapter la législation et les critères
aux réalité rurales si spécifiques le
rapport traite aussi des infrastructures
de réseau que sont les transports et le
numérique là encore mes chers collègues
je crois qu'il faut être clair et
affirmer la nécessité de ne pas laisser
à la seule initiative privée le choix de
la localisation des réseaux à défaut ce
sont des pans entiers du territoire qui
resteront au banc de la la révolution
numérique pourtant les financements
existent je vous rappelle ici que la
rente du cuive au profit de France
tellécom société aujourd'hui privatisé
permet à cette société un taux de
profitabilité maximum de l'ordre de 28
milliards sur 5 années une telle somme
aurait permis le fibrage de l'ensemble
du
territoire je raccourcis monsieur le
Président pour finir je voudrais
souligner l'importance de la
revitalisation des Bours permettant de
ne pas empiéter inutilement sur les
terres agricoles par ailleurs la
diversification de l'agriculture de
proximité doit être favorisée nous
serons à ce titre très attentif aux
évolutions de la
PAC alors que 40 % de citadins
d'agglomération de plus de 100000
habitants souhaitent s'installer à la
campagne soit 8 millions de personnes
aspirant ainsi une meilleure qualité de
vie plus enem prise avec la terre et la
nature il faut que les pouvoirs publics
permettent concrètement d'accueillir ces
nouveaux habitants il faut maintenant
relever le défi et poser des actes pour
le changement en conclusion le monde
rural français mérite de nouau
et de nouveau critères d'attribution les
élus raux seront faire le reste faites
le confiance merci Monsieur le
C la parole dans la suite du débat est à
Monsieur em de montesqu pour 5
minutes président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues fondamentaliste de
la ruralité je suis convcu synonyme de
modernité la transformation
spectaculaire du monde rural ces
dernières années le confirme les défis
qui s'offr à lui sont nombreux j'en
retiendrai trois l'accès au trèsh haut
débit sur tout le territoire dans les
meilleurs délais doit être l'une de vos
priorités nous savons le coût
considérable d'un tel objectif mais il
faudrait un plan similaire au plan
téléphone qu'avait lancé et réalisé le
président giscardestin au coout aussi
très élevé pour connecter tous les
Français à moyen terme les zones
blanches sont encore trop nombreuses
handicapent les zones rurales aucun de
leurs habitants ne peut aujourd'hui
vivre sans Internet ni les agriculteurs
ni les viticulteurs qui remplissent des
déclarations désormais dématérialisées
ni les entreprises qui s'implantent en
milieu rural et qui en sont dépendantes
pour leur implantation et leur
développement quel est le calendrier
d'un aménagement numérique des territoir
ruraux du du gouvernement qui
permettrait de surcroix d'exploiter
pleinement la taille de notre territoire
le Sud-Ouest est une zone souvent
touchée par la sécheresse il manque
cruellement de retenue d'eau les
agriculteurs sont dans l'incapacité de
récupérer et de stocker les eaux
pluviales particulièrement abondantes
cette année faute de réservoir les
spécialistes de l'eau estiment que la
collecte de 1 % 1 % des précipitations
du mois de janvier aurait assuré plus
que l'arrosage de l'année la création de
retenu est donc une nécessité à grande
comme à petite échelle pour augmenter la
productivité à l'hectare les
agriculteurs sont favorables et prêts à
investir dans les réserves d'eau or
plusieurs freins réglementaires existent
et devrai être levés relèvement des se
d'autorisation suppression des délais de
recours et prise en compte de mesures de
compensation en cas de CR tion de
réserve sur cours d'eau ou zone humide à
l'échelle locale à l'échelle locale le
Gers par exemple a toujours favorisé la
création de retenu culinaire pour
l'irrigation souvent de volume modeste à
quand la concrétisation du projet de
décret prévoyant une simplification
administrative pour les petits ouvrages
retenant moins de 5000 m C en les
retirant de la classe D à plus grande
échelle le Bage de charas irriguerait
six départements dans deux régions
projet intelligent et bien pensé il fait
la quasi unanimité des responsables
politiques de la région quelle est votre
position sur ce dossier monsieur le
ministre un autre défi les exportation
la France 4e exportateur mondial
traditionnellement grand exportateur
agroalimentaire est surclassé dans
certains secteurs et talonné dans tous
les autres par l'Allemagne
ou pourtant les terres sont de moins
bonne qualité le climat moins favorable
et la tradition agricole moins marquée
qu'en France ce paradoxe est donc cette
anomalie traduis certainement les
faiblesses de l'organisation et du
financement de l'agriculture française
la stratégie industrielle allemande de
concentration des industries
agroalimentaires d'aide à l'export de
réduction du coût de travail à augmenté
la compétitivité de ces produits un
exemple édif
pour la baisse de nos charges notre
difficulté à exporter ne vient pas dans
la quasi-totalité des cas de la qualité
de nos produits mais de leur coût dans
le secteur Salier ces coûts risquent de
nous couper du marché international et
de nous faire supplanter par les Russes
ou les Ukrainiens voire même par les
Kazaks alors qu'il existe un potentiel
considérable au regard de l'augmentation
de la population mondiale dans les 20
anné à venir cette projection devrait
rassurer nos agriculteurs si on leur
donne les moyens d'en profiter en
baissant leur charge monsieur le
ministre vous connaissez
l'agriculture je souhaite que vous
preniez en compte ces probl
problématique simple qui mettent
quasiment à chaque fois en cause le coût
de nos
productions merci mon cher collègue
merci Monsieur em de
montesqu la parole monsieur chistian
bourin monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre de la
ruralité de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et d'autres choses mes
chers
collègues quel nouveau défi pour le
monde rural voilà un débat qui tombe à
point nommé dans la foulée de la
publication du rapport sénatorial de
prospective qui interroge l'avenir de
nos campagnes mais aussi à la veille de
l'ouverture du nouveau volet
2014-2020 de la politique de cohésion
européenne sur ce point je crois qu'il
serait utile de s'interroger sur
l'utilisation au niveau national des
investisss territoriaux intégrés ils
sont encore pour l'essentiel concentrés
sur les villes ou vers les villes qui
profitent le cas échéant et paricochés à
leurs alentours on appelle ça les
interlandes rien pourtant ne nous
empêche de recourir à cet instrument
destiné à promouvoir une approche locale
de développement pour appuyer les
projets communaux ou régionaux pour la
ruralité tout laisse à croire d'ailleurs
et je le développerai tout l'URE que les
habitants des villes sont loin de se
désintéresser des possibilités de vie
offertes loin de leur mur à la condition
que les riantes campagnes dans
lesquelles ils aimeraient désormais
pouvoir s'installer soi aménagé tel est
Monsieur le Ministre la ruralité le
changement de paradigme que j'appelle de
mes vœux car il est bien là ce nouveau
cadre général dans lequel on gagnerit à
resituer les nouveaux enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire créer une
vitable solidarité républicaine entre le
monde urbain et rural non pas conçu
comme une démarche de sauvotage d'un
monde rural considéré depuis la capitale
comme un lieu trop particulier car pas
assez peuplé mais une démarche visant à
organiser des échanges fructueux entre
nos villes et nos campagnes à déployer
de véritables projets structurant pour
voyeurs d'avenir qui pourrait être à
l'initiative même des territoires
ruraux le monde rural cela a été rappelé
au cours de ce débat représente 80 % du
territoire et 20 % de la
population cela étant posé je pense que
nous sommes tous d'accord c'est en effet
le cœur de la proposition de résolution
relative au développement par l'état
d'une politique d'égalité des
territoires déposé d'ailleurs par mon
groupe et voté à l'unanimité par le
Sénat pour dire pour dire mes chers
collègues que seul l'angle démographique
et comptable ne constitue pas ce qui
doit structurer une politique publique
digne de ce nom pour le monde
rural je renvoie notamment au binô en
outre cette réalité territoriale rurale
n'est pas homogène il faut distinguer ce
qui relève de la ruralité il est sur ce
point très significatif d'observer que
la caractérise par
défaut puisque l'Institut considère
qu'elle englobe tout ce qui n'est pas
une unité
urbaine quand même ce qui relève donc de
l'hyperruralité cette dernière se
caractérisant par un éloignement
généralisé des services publics de la
culture des cabinets médicaux des
universités des pharmacies et même des
commerces de bouche des épiceries et des
boulangeries enfin les territoires
ruraux ne constitue pas des zones figées
dans le temps là aussi la donne change
ainsi depuis une quinzaine d'années on
constate que des nouvelles populations
s'y installent elles sont en quête d'un
mode de vie plus harmonieux plus proche
de la nature tout en exprimant le
souhait de ne pas renoncer à ce que trop
longtemps les pouvoirs publics ont
procuré en priorité aux urbain certains
font ainsi le choix d'y passer leur
temps libre d'autres d'y acquérir une
résidence secondaire d'autres aimeraient
s'y installer mais à la condition de
pouvoir y trouver de nouveaux
équipements un accès au services publics
une connexion permanente à l'ex avec
l'extérieur la possibilité d'utiliser
les nouvelles technologies de
communication je souhaiterais écarter
d'emblé la question de l'accessibilité
de ces dernières technologies non pas
que l'enjeu soit tenu au contraire il
est l'une des conditions syineéquanon de
la réussite des territoires ruraux
notamment en terme d'accès au services
publics mais il n'entre pas dans le
sujet du débat d'aujourd'hui du moins je
le considère comme cela en matière
d'accès au haut débit en effet les
décisions ont été déjà prise il s'agit
de rattraper le retard pris dans leur
mise en œuvre pas de travestir un ancien
dossier pour le présenter comme un
nouveau projet pour ce qui concerne les
nouveaux défis à relever pour les
territoires ruraux on peut dégager deux
axes de réflexion si vous le voulez bien
mes chers collègues le premier axe
concerne la gouvernance le second la
mise en valeur du potentiel de nos
territoires concernant la pertinence du
choix de gouvernance pour le monde rural
elle constitue en elle-même un enjeu
important les zones rurales s'appuie
encore aujourd'hui sur un découpage très
traditionnel de la représentation
démographique démocratique elle s'appuie
sur les communes et les cantons or dans
bien des cas on constate que la commune
n'est plus en capacité de répondre seu
aux besoins d'aménagement il en' démeure
pas moins le lieu de vie par excellence
l'espace incontournable de proximité
sociale de l'expression républicaine et
deschanges toutefois c'est bien souvent
à la communauté commune de prendre le
relais en matière d'investissement et de
gestion
par exemple pour acquérir et faire
fonctionner des équipements lourds et
coûteux ce qui nécessite la mobilisation
de capacités financière
mutualisé la réflexion sur le
développement d'une manière générale
gagnerait ainsi à être appréendé au
moyen d'échelle plus pertinente dans la
logique des bassins de vie c'est le
principe par exemple qui pré présidait à
la création des parcs naturels régionaux
je constate que ces derniers tendent à
être désormais comme des outils de
protection au sens strict par certains
observateurs c'est là bien une étrange
vision étriqué appauvri réductrice et
c'est bien dommage quant au bassin de
vie on pourrait également avec profit
veiller à leur intégration dans un
ensemble plus large irrigué par les
réseaux de transport les flux et les
échanges économiques avec les
agglomérations accueillant des espaces
de loisirs c'est la vis
développé dans la révision du schéma
régional d'aménagement et développement
durable du territoire que j'ai conduit
dans ma région en langue Rousillon avec
notamment la définition vous qui
appréciez d'avant
pays à titre d'exemple et je vous
donnerai un exemple avant que vous
disiez
bravo celui de laè et oui l'exemple de
la est C aéroports du langoc
Rousillon qui ne sont pas en loser et
bien je vais vous dire ces cinq
aéroports procurent un chiffre
d'affaires en loser de 10 millions
d'euros alors que l'aéroport le plus
près se trouve à 180 km c'est cela
l'unité
régionale je vous remercie
d'apprécier rapidement
parce que le temps me manque et que vous
déviez de mon vous me déviez de mon
propos c'est terminé j'aimerais évoquer
les atouts du monde rural et ils sont
nombreux monsieur le ministre vous les
connaissez je le sais en premier lieu le
monde rural et son monde de vie monsieur
le Président juste quelques
instants le monde rural et son mode de
vie sont attrayants comme je l'ai évoqué
certains souhaitent s'y installer
d'autres y avoir des loisirs les besoins
que les uns et les autres expriment vont
dans le sens de la qualité de vie
toujours la qualité de vie et donc du
maintien des services et du maillage
territorial le maintien des activité
agricole est également un enjeu fort en
terme d'emploi dans le secteur même de
la production dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire
afférant mais aussi en terme d'entretien
des paysages avec une exploitation
agricole qui disparaît c'est tout un
espace qui se
referme dans ma région toujours
l'exemple en
l'oction nous savons ainsi très bien que
l'arrachage des vignes constitue un
désastre pour l'emploi pour l'économie
viticole vinicole mais aussi un
repoussoir pour tous ceux qui viennent
s'inspirer et s'imprégner de la culture
méditerranéenne mais je pourrais citer
l'exemple de la Bretagne quand un
Maré mais bien entendu c'est nous la
France et quand un un Maré
se referme et bien c'est des
inondations
derrière d'une transition
énergétique création d'emplo péren je P
à l'au je pense au bois je
pense je pense à la pêche à la chasse
toute cette série d'activités qui font
vivre le
territoire
le président va vouloir que encore plus
oui surtout j'essaie de couper que ça
marche pas pour
conclure pruralité des projets Ambit
résolument modern je souhaite que le
prochain rapport de la prospective du
Sénat les concernant contrairement à
celui qui vire rendu tout aussi
excellent DEP soir n'aborde plus la
question du moin des a envisager mais
celui du meilleur voilà monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre voilà
tracer quelques pistes de l'avenir de la
ruralité en France
Merci excusez-moi ouais mais c'est pas
sérieux la parole est à Monsieur Joël
Labé rien
faire président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues là j'ai une
succession difficile à assurer mon
prédécesseur il il a pensé à la Bretagne
en tant que territoire français me vient
une idée par rapport aux espaces ruraux
ne sont pas abordé mais ce n'était pas
le sujet les espaces maritimes qui
quelque part font partie de la de la
ruralité au sens
large la France demeure un espace
essentiellement rural maillé par près de
30 communes rurales qui font notre
richesse et qui représente 78 78 % du
territoire et encore 22 % de la
population comme le dit dans le rapport
la la prospectiviste édit
Orgon on ne peut dissocier l'avenir des
campagnes de l'avenir des villes et l'un
des défis du monde contemporain
justement de réinventer nos territoires
vers des devenirs souhaitables devenir
plutôt qu'avenir d'ailleurs si l'avenir
est ce que nous prévoyons le devenir est
ce que nous construisons ensemble
construire ensemble implique de partager
certains
constats et ce rapport qui est qui est
bien bien complet nous permet justement
de faire un état des lieux et je
voudrais saluer le le travail
remarquable qui a été réalisé et qui
nous permet de de se rapprocher sur les
sur les les premières la première
analyse le profil économique de l'espace
rural et de l'espace urbain ne sont pas
si différents il apparaît que les
services sont les premiers pourvoyeurs
d'emploi dans les deux catégories
d'espace suivi de l'industrie sans
surprise l'agriculture tient une place
particulière à la croisée de ces espaces
sans surprise une fois de plus hélas
l'emploi agricole subit une érosion
continue à rapproché évidemment avec
l'augmentation de la taille des
exploitations concernant l'industrie les
implantation rurale résiste en dépit de
la tendance générale à la
désindustrialisation notamment en raison
de délocalisation d'établissement en
provenance des villes ce qui arrive et
qui est une chance mais ce sont les
activités TER tertiires qui progressent
le plus avec une croissance annuelle de
plus de 2 % dans l'espace à dominante
rurale or à la différence de l'espace
urbain les services il sont presque
exclusivement tournés vers la population
locale petit commerce santé
administration la nécessaire
redynamisation des territoires ruraux
doit doit pouvoir s'appuyer sur les
réseaux des petites et moyennes villes
et des bourgs dotés d'équipement
structurant et de l'ensemble des
services à la à la population tout comme
le haut débit généralisé qui est attendu
avec impatience et ainsi les territoires
ruraux doivent rester ce qu'ils sont une
chance pour la France les territoires
ruraux sont des espaces où
l'expérimentation de terrain
l'innovation le besoin d'interactivité
et d'une logique de recherche qui ne
soit pas que descendant sont très
importants et ce constat vaut pour
toutes les activités économiques mais
j'aborderai plus particulièrement le
développement agricole de ces
territoires tout d'abord les attentes
environnementales sont au cœur des
demandes de la société elle pourrait et
devrait constituer de ce fait un moteur
économique fondamental en orientant les
activité agricole pour répondre à ses
attentes un nouveau modèle agricole est
nécessaire il devra s'appuyer notamment
sur une agriculture nouvelle que
Monsieur le le ministre vous appelez
agroécologie une une agriculture qui
prennent en compte l'environnement et
qui doit reposer sur une protection des
espaces multifonctionnels et en premier
lieu ce qui remplissent une fonction
dans le maintien durable des ressources
naturelles la reproduction de la
feralité de la ilité et la lutte contre
les ravageurs les espaces agricoles
gagneraient ainsi en fonctionnalité
écologique et permettraient une
restauration des espèces communes et
remarqua qui en dépendent il s'agit de
permettre le développement d'une
agriculture qui ne subit pas les
nécessaires normes environnemental comme
autant de contraintes mais au contraire
tout en produisant devient une activité
essentielle pour la préservation des
équilibres et de la biodiversité il
s'agit également de favoriser une
agriculture qui soit de prox prox imité
et qui répondent à la demande des
produits alimentaires locaux sains et de
qualité or l'un des freins au
développement de ce type d'agriculture
est celui de la pression urbaine qui
entraîne notamment une sur une
surévaluation du prix du foncier il
devient aujourd'hui urgent d'adopter une
stratégie d'aménagement du territoire où
monde urbain rural et agricole se
rencontre davantage afin de favoriser
notamment le développement d'une
agriculture de proximité par des projets
via
cohérent et concerté réformer la
politique foncière agricole est un défi
lourd mais c'est aussi un formidable
levier pour faire évoluer notre modèle
agricole et de production et pour que
celui-ci soit plus acceptable
socialement économiquement viable et
durable le productivisme agricole appuyé
sur l'agrochimie la financiarisation des
matières premières et la et la et de la
transformation nous mène droit dans le
mur les éleveurs aujourd'hui sont
acculés les abattoirs de proximité
ferment c'est le cas pour la Bretagne
nous réaffirmons que la sécurité
alimentaire et la la traçabilité des
produits sont une priorité de santé
publique et notre législation doit être
amélioré en ce sens je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Joël
Labé la parole est à Monsieur Benoît
Huré pour 9
minutes
bonjour monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mes chers
collègues je suis très heureux que ce
débat a lieu et de pouvoir y
contribuer au-delà de celui-ci c'est
sans doute un débat sociétal voire
social qu'il
ouvre en effet 90 % de la population
française sur 10 % du territoire
est-ce encore acceptable pour
longtemps même si pour la plupart des
territoires ruraux la situation n'est
plus celle si bien exprimé dans les
années 60 par Jean FERR et sa célèbre
chanson la montagne qu'il aurait pu
intituler la campagne je cite il quitent
un à un le pays pour s'en aller gagner
leur vie loin de la terre où ils sont
nés pour que cette
situation ne soit une
fatalité les élus ont tenté de mettre en
place des politiques visant à rayer ce
déclin démographique en redonnant aux
habitants de ces territoirees et
notamment à sa jeunesse de bonnes
raisons de faire le choix de rester au
pays depuis
1975 le déclin démographique s'est
progressivement inversé pour connaître
aujourd'hui une véritable accélération
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
enfin les communes rurales voient
s'ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives du
fait des évolutions sociologique
économique et des infrastructures qui
désenclabent nombre de territoires
ruraux les nouveaux habitants de nos
territoires que ce soit ceux qui y sont
nés ou ceux qui ont quitté la ville pour
venir s'y
enraciner font le choix d'une certaine
qualité de vie et du cadre de vie
préservé mais ils attendent également
des services nouveaux qui leur
permettent de concilier leurs activités
familiales ou professionnelles et la vie
en monde rural à savoir des services
éducatifs de bon niveau et cela passe
par la création de crèches de halte
garderie dont les horaires d'ouverture
prennent en compte les temps de
transport des parents travaillant à
l'extérieur mais aussi d'écoes
primairire de qualité associé à un
service périscolaire adapté des
équipements sportifs et culturels animé
par une vie associative danse un réseau
de communication performant aussi bien
routiers que d'Internet à haut débit ou
de téléphonie mobile des commerces et
artisans de proximité des services de
soins et de santé moderne avec des
maisons de santé où se regroupent les
différentes professions médicales et
paramédicales cette manière de
travailler en équipe est un préalable
indispensable à laavenue de jeunes
praticien gagner ainsi la bataille de la
croissance démographique c'est d'emblé
tout un ensemble d'activités et de
services de proximité qui trouve les
moyens de s'y développer et cela repose
en grande partie sur la volonté et
l'action des collectivité
territoriale les collectivités doivent
favoriser et accompagner ses créations
s'appuyer sur un maillage de Bours
centre et de petites communes qui
trouvent leur équilibre au travers d'une
intercommunalité plus petite à qui le
maximum de compétences a été transféré
par les communes
mutualisant rationalisant et coordonnant
mieux les moyens publics les grandes
communautés de communes sans cohérence
territoriale répondent très
difficilement à cette nécessité et leurs
promoteurs sont comparables à ceux qui
dans un autre domaine confondent
chiffres d'affaires et bénéfices les
collectivités doivent aussi participer
aux investissements dans l'immobilier
que ce soit celui d'entreprise artisanal
commercial et de service mais aussi
celui de l'immobilier locatif car nous
assist
à une augmentation du nombre de foyers
rencontrant les plus grandes difficultés
à pouvoir emprunter pour devenir
propriétaire de leur logement les
collectivités doivent aussi participer
aux investissements dans la santé la
petite enfance et l'épaule scolaire
moderne avec la généralisation des
écoles numériques durables
elles doivent aussi faciliter
l'émergence d'un tissu associatif
rendant le territoire vivant et
permettant d'y trouver les mêmes
activités sportive et culturel qu'en
ville elles doivent aussi construire un
réseau de transport collectif dont le
covoiturage cela pour réduire le coût du
transport dans le budget des ménages
ruraux cette énumération n'est pas
exhaustive loin de favoriser les
villages d'ortoir le nouvel espace rural
doit être attractif et actif comme
l'avait si bien défini et démontré notre
collègue Jean-François
Poncet revivifier cet espace rural
pourra amplifier et conforter son
développement à travers l'agriculture
pierre angulaire du monde rural
l'artisanat le commerce les services le
tourisme le télétravail bref toutes les
formes d'économie résidentielle ainsi
que l'économie sociale et solidaire à
qui il offre les plus sûrs moyens d'un
ancrage
durable pour arriver à ce renouveau de
la ruralité ces différents acteurs élus
mais aussi responsables
socio-économiques doivent faire preuve
d'une grande ténacité parce que
régulièrement les décideurs parisiens
nont de cesse de tenter de réduire le
peu de moyens publics nécessaires et ils
ont d'ailleurs parfois réussi si au
cours ces 30 dernières années a pu être
enrayer le déclin du monde rural
aujourd'hui pour relever les nouveaux
défis de la ruralité dont j'ai donné
quelques exemples précédemment nous
avons plus que jamais besoin du soutien
de l'État et des financements publics
qui vont avec
nous avons aussi besoin que celui-ci
soit le garant d'une péréquation entre
métropole et territoire très riches et
le reste de la France l'écart de
richesse entre territoires c'est
fortement accentué devient inacceptable
voire
indécent il va à l'encontre de l'égalité
des citoyens et compromet autant leur
confiance dans les élus que la
crédibilité de nos institutions et
l'unité même de notre
République trois décisions gouvern ale
récente me préoccupe au plus haut
point le choix de l'organisation du
territoire français autour de très
grandes métropoles concentrant à terme
l'essentiel des moyens publics la baisse
importante et même inquiétante des
dotations de l'État au collectivités
locales une première sous la 5e
République elle a pour conséquence
d'affaiblir encore plus les territoires
fragiles qu'il soit ruraux ou urbains
d'ailleurs parce que pour ces
territoires l'essentiel de leurs moyens
pour fonctionner et investir provient
des dotations de l'État alors que dans
les métropoles et territoires riches
c'est la fiscalité économique qui est
primordiale enfin la réforme des
conseils généraux aboutira à une
diminution très importante du nombre
d'élus sur les territoires ruraux et
fragiles et donc de leurs défenseurs qui
sont les mieux à même de porter les
aspirations et les attentes de la
population par ailleurs la concentration
de l'État en région au détriment de sa
proximité dans les départements outre le
coût supplémentaire et la loudeur du
fonctionnement pour tous les acteurs de
proximité rendra incontestablement
l'état plus lointain au risque de le
mettre en décalage avec toute cette
réalité territoriale qui est une
richesse pour notre pays et qui le sera
peut-être encore plus demain au regard
notamment des enjeux énergétiques et des
outils de croissance qu'il faudra
valoriser
même si j'ai l'habitude de dire que le
pire n'est pas certain ce qui est
certain aujourd'hui c'est qu'il va
falloir se mobiliser pour faire prendre
en compte les légitimes aspirations du
monde rural et la nécessité pour l'état
de les traiter avec équité ne voyez pas
dans mes propos un esprit polémique je
n'ai pas attendu le printemps 2012 pour
découvrir l'état calamiteux des finances
publiques et je sais depuis longtemps
que nous devrons participer à la
résorption des déficits à condition que
l'effort nécessaire soit équitablement
réparti monsieur le ministre alors
Monsieur le Ministre quelle est votre
vision de l'avenir pour le monde rural
et quel moyen êtes-vous prêt à mettre
avec les acteurs locaux pour y relever
rapidement tous les nouveaux défis selon
moi mettre fin un certain nombre
d'inégalités sera serait déjà un début
de réponse pourquoi pas une DGF ramené à
l'habitant égal en rural et en urbain
alors qu'aujourd'hui elle va du simple
au double il en va de même pour la DSR
par habitant au regard de la DSU par
habitant pourquoi ne pas renforcer et
accélérer la péréquation horizontale
c'est-à-dire un début de la partage des
richesses entre territoires riches et
territoires pauvres c'est la même que la
majorité précédente a commencé à mettre
en place et qui ne représente pourtant à
ce jour que 2 % des richesses or
l'enveloppe déjà insuffisante a été
récemment uté d'une partie des somme
pour qu'à la faveur d'une modification
réglementaire dans la dernière loi de
financeces des territoires comme la scè
saintis ou les BOUCHES DU rô puissent en
bénéficier monsieur le ministre vouloir
réduire significativement les écarts de
richesse entre les grandes métropoles et
le reste de la France c'est rétablir une
égalité entre les territoires et faire
un investissement d'avenir pour la
France je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Monsieur Benoît Huré
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Luc ficher
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis cet après-midi pour débattre des
nouveaux défis du monde rural mais de
quel nouveau défi
parle-t-on notre pays est confronté à
une grave crise économique provoquée par
la folie bancaire et
financière le changement voulu par les
Français au printemps dernier nous a
donné de nouvelles perspective pour
l'emploi et la
croissance notre pays reste confronté à
de grands défis lutter contre le chômage
recréer des emplois dans l'industrie
repenser l'école et l'apprentissage
réformer l'État aller vers un nouveau
modèle d'agriculture et repenser la
filière
agroalimentaire répondre aux angoisses
de nos concitoyens en matière d'accès au
logement mais également sur tout ce qui
concerne leur santé et leur alimentation
alors que l'Europe est frappée par un
nouveau scandale alimentaire c'est dans
ce tableau général et à long d'une
nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation poser la question des
nouveaux défis du monde rural la
population des communes de moins de 2000
habitants a progressé en moyenne de 1,3
% par an entre 99 et
2006 nos territoires d'aujourd'hui et de
demain sont le fruit de ce nouvel espoir
d'un mieux viv tout en étant confronté à
de vraies questions d'aménagement du
territoire et de développement
économique je rappelle ici la nomination
utile par le Premier ministre d'un
ministre en charge de l'égalité des
territoires l'égalité des territoires
voilà un des premiers grands défis du
monde rural aujourd'hui permettez-moi de
développer deux exemples l'égalité 2.0
et l'égalité d'accès aux soins l'égalité
2.0 si nous ne parvenons pas à connecter
au très haut débit chaque Bour chaque
hameau chaque maison chaque quartier
autant dire que nous ne ferons que
maintenir des territoires en respiration
artificiel dans ma région en Bretagne le
schéma de cohérence régionale
d'aménagement numérique du territoire a
défini l'ambition des collectivités
bretonnes pour apporter le très haut ni
niveau le Très Haut Débit pardon à à
tous à l'horizon
2030 afin de maintenir la cohésion du
territoire le principe est simple une
ligne fibrée en ville égale une ligne
fibrée dans le monde
rural le financement de ce projet repose
sur une péréquation régionale favorable
aux territoires ruraux ce projet a été
salué par Madame flore pèin minist
minist en charge de l'économie numérique
le 16 novembre dernier le déploiement du
très haut débit est bien un axe
structurant d'aménagement du territoire
l'égalité d'accès aux soins autre sujet
autre défi qui se pose au monde rural
l'accès aux soins les maires en sont
pleinement conscien l'absence de
médecins pose un problème majeur
d'égalité des territoires d'égalité et
de justice entre les citoyens c'est le
cœur du travail que j'ai mené tout ment
avec notre collègue Hervé Moret sur les
déserts
médicaux madame Marisol Touren ministre
des Affaires sociale et de la santé a
pris 12 engagements pour un Pact
territoire santé si ce plan est
essentiel nous avons souhaité aller plus
loin au regard d'une situation de plus
en plus compliquée pour les communes les
mesures structurell et incitativ ont une
portée encore trop limitée si les
solutions Prenn forcément du temps nous
estimons que des mesures plus
volontaristes sont indispensables dans
le seul souci de l'intérêt général il
nous faut agir sur tous les leviers que
cela soit la conception des études de
médecine les modes de rémunération des
médecins les incitations financières
existantes le conventionnement sélectif
des médecins ou encore l'obligation pour
les médecins spécialistes d'exercer
pendant 2 ans à la fin de leurs études
dans des Hau de proximité ces mesures
sont vitales pour l'avenir des
territoires ruraux et elles sont un
véritable défi pour un nouveau Pact
territorial un autre défi nous attend
que les communes du monde rural soient
mieux représenté dans les instances du
gouvernant de gouvernance territoriale
je représente aujourd'hui devant la
délégation collectivité territoriale et
à la décentralisation un rapport avec
mon collègue Stéphane Mazar sur les
nouveaux outils de la politique
d'aménagement du territoire les débats
qui ont accompagné l'adoption de loi de
la loi créant la banque publique
d'investissement ont mis en relief les
doutes relatifs à l'efficacité de
l'action économique des collectivités
territoriales et pourtant l'organisation
de l'espace la répartition des hommes
des activités des infrastructures au
niveau régionale ne serait être la
résultante de politiqu menées
individuellement sans concertation ni
coordination
l'action des collectivités territoriales
est réelle mais elle est peut-être mal
appréhendée en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux nous devons donc
travailler à la rendre plus lisible
notamment à travers les schémas
régionaux d'aménagement et développement
durable du territoire les strates
l'action des collectivités territoriales
rural et n'oublions pas qu'au total
l'investissement des collectivités pour
le développement économique a dépassé
5,3 milliards d'euros en 2010 selon la
DGL donc je vais aller à la conclusion
puisque j'ai un rappel en conclusion je
souhaitais insister sur la nécessité de
maintenir un haut niveau
d'investissement des collectivités
territoriales et tout particulièrement
de celle du monde rural car par cet
outil que nous pourrons naître les
nouvelles perspectives de croissance
ainsi chaque acteur du pacte républicain
a son rôle à jouer dans la réduction des
déficits attention à ne pas brider trop
durement le nécessaire développement de
nos territoires et engageons un nouveau
Pact territorial favorable à l'emploi et
et à la croissance je vous remercie
merci Monsieur donné la parole dans la
suite du débat est à Monsieur Philippe
B pardon je m'excuse je m'excuse c'est à
vous monsieur tant
donné autant pour moi comme on
dit et ensuite Monsieur Philippe Bas je
m'excuse
bonjour
on voulait pas écarter les ruraux quand
même monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
questions rurales ont un impact
particulier au Sénat car notre chambre
est naturellement très attachée au
territoire et à leur développement
j'aimerais saluer ici le travail de nos
collègues René niikou et Gérard bai dans
le rapport d'information l'avenir des
campagnes fera référence en terme de
nouveaux défis du monde rural je
regrette que le gouvernement ne nous
donne pas l'occasion d'être entendu par
madame la ministre de l'Égalité des
territoires les Défis Ruraux reposent
sur cette problématique centrale je ne
reviendrai donc pas sur les défis que
constituent les déserts médicaux la
valorisation du bâtier existant ou
encore l'accessibilité des transports il
me semble cependant important d'insister
sur deux points premièrement la ruralité
reste une réelle alternative à la
métropolisation galopante les petites et
moyennes villes sont au développement
des campagnes environnantes mais aussi
de véritables bassins de vie l'exemple
réussi de l'implantation de l'École
nationale d'administration pénitentiaire
à agun dans le lotgaron avec ses 6000
élèves par an dans un campus performant
et moderne à dynamiser le territoire en
renforçant la présence étudiante et en
créant des emplois évitons d'amplifier
un phénomène de concentration déjà
excessif pourquoi ne pas diriger vers
les villes moyennes et les territoires
ruraux des emplois contraints
administratif et tertia rendu possible
par les nouvelles technologies qui
effacent les distances c'est d'ailleurs
mon second point la cohésion du
territoire son accessibilité et sa
valorisation ne se feront pas sans les
sort du numérique le défi de la
couverture numérique est un vrai motif
d'inquiétude tant au niveau national
qu'à l'échelle de mon
département un territoire rural peut
bénéficier d'un réel développement et
présenter une forte attractivité si sa
couverture numérique est satisfaisante
dans le cas inverse il connaîtra un
déclin inexorable à ce titre je regrette
que le
famt demeure à à ce jour une coquille
vide la proposition de loi de mon
collègue centriste Hervé Moré aurait
pourtant aidé à dégager des recettes
permettant au gouvernement d'abonder ce
fond il est urgent de prendre des
engagements sur la véritable mise en
place du haut débit pour tous cela ne se
fera pas sans une recette dédiée au
déploement de la au déploiement de la
fibre optique dans les territoires
ruraux une tx tax indolore sur le prix
des consommations électroniques serait
une réponse adaptée pourquoi toujours
ces mêmes rétisence d' et d'aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet les points que je viens
d'évoquer témoignent d'un monde rural
qui s'est profondément métamorphosé au
cours des dernières 15 années bien sûr
demè des questions structurantes pour
nos territoires ruraux liés au défis
agricoles à l'heure actuelle la
redéfinition de la pâack constitue
l'engé essentiel pour nos agriculteurs
après l'accord du 8 février
pour un budget PCT de 362 milliards
d'euros soit une baisse de 13,7 % par
rapport à l'exercice précédent c'est
avant tout la mise en œuvre de cette P
qui sera un réel défi monsieur le
ministre je souhaite insister sur les
filières spécialisées qui sont trop peu
souvent évoqués ces secteurs tels que
celui de la prune représentent beaucoup
d'emplois locaux au service de la
production de qualité ces filièr
participe à l'identité de nos
territoires les arbitrages que vous
devrez effectuer sur ces enjeux dans les
mois à venir seront de la plus haute
importance sur la périnité de ces
filières le système le système de
soutien à l'agriculture qui existe est
en train d'être réformé et les débats
sur les possibles mesures
environnementales comme les subventions
accordées aux exploitations ne cessent
d'alimenter l'actualité
agricole dans le cadre de la
redéfinition de la PAC j'attire tout
particulièrement votre attention sur
l'exemple de la prune dans le découplage
des aides à montrer ses limites les
pruniculteurs sont en train de lancer un
plan de relance des vergers par une
production plus respectueuse de
l'environnement est plus rentable en
matière de vergers un certain nombre
d'années Caire est nécessaire pour
atteindre un taux de rentabilité
satisfaisant c'est pourquoi un soutien
de la PAC lié à la production de prunau
et qui aille au-delà de l'aide directe
pendant la période de relance du verger
est essentielle pour ces acteurs cet
exemple peut se décliner sur d'autres
filières de
fruits
enfin mon dernier point sur la porte sur
la gestion des ressources en eau la
pluie tombée en abondance dernièrement
ramène sur le devant de la scène la
question de la gestion et donc du
stockage de la ressource en eau le
réchauffement climatique que
particulièrement dans le Sud-Ouest fait
craindre des conditions de plus en plus
méditerranenes et donc des périodes de
séchesse plus longues face à cela comme
on souvent pu le dire des spécialistes
de la question soit on subit soit on
anticipe
la sécurisation des cultures
spécialisées mais aussi la
contractualisation contractualisation
agricole ne peuvent s'opérer sans
garantie de la ressource en eau force de
constater que la gestion de l'eau répond
à des conflits d'usage je constate dans
ma région que la métropole toulousaine
qui grandit se développe nécessite des
ressources importants il y a 15000
habitants de plus sur la métropole
toulousaine chaque année pourquoi alors
ne pas créer des réserves d'eau la
création de lac collinaire pourrait
contribuer à une importante sécurisation
des productions et au maintien des
exploitations familiales par ailleurs la
création de réserves de substitution
gérée collectivement pourrait soulager
la pression sur le fleuve Garon dans le
Sud-Ouest le projet de barrage de
charlass qui pourrait être une réelle
opportunité reste cependant au point
mort pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre ces
projets ne progressent-ils pas donc en
conclusion je voulais insister sur le
fait que l'environnement l'eau
l'agriculture forme un tout indivisible
pour nos territoires ruraux les
agriculteurs en sont les partenaires à
part entière et constituent les
gestonnières essentielles de notre monde
rural il ne faut pas les oublier et au
contraire les associer au développement
de notre ruralité je vous remercie merci
Monsieur tant donné dans la suite du
débat la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Bas
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues nous avons pris l'habitude de
traiter la question de la
ruralité et la question de la ville
comme si elles étaient séparées elles
sont en réalité complémentaires or tout
ce pass maintenant comme si la ruralité
était ignorée au profit des banlieu sans
pour autant que la concentration des
crédits de l'aménagement du territoire
au service des problématiques urbaines
ne permettent au quartiers difficile de
trouver réellement un nouvel
équilibre dans le même temps nous voyons
les crédits liés à l'amélioration de
l'habitat rural s'amenuiser voire
disparaître les écoles
les bureaux de poste et les gendarmeries
se regroupai de même que les services
hospitaliers et les médecins de campagne
partirent en retraite sans être
remplacé le sentiment d'un abandon se
diffuse dans le monde rural et avec lui
une forme de morosité de dépression ou
même de crise il faut
réagir nous avons besoin d'une politique
ambitieuse d'égalité
territoriale pour lutter contre cette
fracture territoriale qui ne cesse de se
creuser le Sénat l'a demandé avec toute
la force de son unanimité en décembre
dernier il attend de la part du
gouvernement une réponse qui soit à la
hauteur des enjeux en 2009 les Assises
des territoires ruraux avaient débouché
sur 40 mesures simples et concrètes le
gouvernement avait alors veillé par la
voix de de Bruno Le Maire a préservé le
financement de ces mesures de tout gel
des dépenses pendant la période
2010-23 les zones de revitalisation
rurale et les pôles de compétitivité ont
ainsi pu être renforcé 2 milliards du
plan de relance ont par ailleurs été
fléchés vers le déploiement des réseaux
numériques dans les zones
délaissé l'État s'est aussi engagé à
participer fortement au financement du
développement rapide des pôles de santé
libéraux ambulatoires et enfin les
maisons de service public en milieu
rural ont bénéficié au cours des années
récentes d'une forte impulsion de même
que la création d'agences postales dans
les mairies qui permettent de préserver
ou de rétablir une certaine proximité
des administrations malgré les
regroupements qui sont opérés
l'utilisation du réseau des
buralistes dans le cadre d'un contrat
avec la profession permet aussi de
donner de nouveaux relais de proximité
au service public cet effort doit être
poursuivi et amplifié non seulement
parce que les valeurs de la ruralité
sont au cœur de notre République mais
aussi parce que le monde rural demeure
une formidable source de richesse pour
notre
pays il garde une formidable vitalité et
comme le soulligne justement l'excellent
rapport d'information de nos collègues
Gérard B et René Nikou les campagnes
dans leur
diversité ne sont pas une charge mais
une chance pour la France l'agriculture
enorte témoignage monsieur le ministre
elle connaît au moins une révolution par
génération peu d'activité pourrait en
dire autant l'économie rurale reste
aujourd'hui fortement liée à
l'agriculture dire cela ce n'est pas
bien sûr méconnaître l'importance du
tissu de nos PME rurale et de notre
artisanat et de nos commerces qui assure
la diversité de l'économie rurale ni
négliger le nécessaire essort de
l'économie numérique ni oublier les
services publics et les services aux
personnes particulièrement ceux qui
touche à la santé ou à l'éducation mais
il serait vain de nier que l'agriculture
tient aujourd'hui la première place avec
l'ensemble des activités qui lui sont
liées or cette richesse là sans laquelle
on ne parlera plus de main de ruralité
est aujourd'hui à plus d'un titre
menacé sur les 7 prochaines années 373
milliards et demi d'euros seront
consacrés à l'agriculture européenne
soit 47 milliards et demi de moins que
sur la période précédente certes cette
baisse de 13 % sera seulement répercutée
à hauteur de 3 % en
France le gouvernement cherche à se
rassurer à nous rassurer en soutenant
que le pire a été évité amère victoire
si c'en est une qui ne doit pas masquer
la réalité au total la France percevra
55,8 milliards entre 2014 et 2020 au
lieu des
57,3 de la période précédente quand on
se souvient des accords de Berlin qui
avait sanctuarisé pour 10 ans le montant
des crédits de la politique agricole
commune quand on se souvient de
l'engagement total
du président Chirac et de son premier
ministre de l'époque je salue
Jean-Pierre rafarin face au chancelier
schreuder pour faire comprendre à nos
partenaires qu'un intérêt vital de la
France était en cause quand on se
souvient de l'accord finalement donné
par l'Allemagne entraînant avec nous une
majorité d'États européens on mesure
combien sont préjudiciables à nos
agriculteurs et à l'ensemble du monde
rural la faiblesse actuelle de la France
sur la scène européenne son isolement
politique face à un axe
germano-britannique qui ne cesse de se
renforcer son manque de volontarisme
aussi pour défendre les intérêts majeurs
de notre agriculture qui sont les
intérêts de la France l'avenir de notre
agriculture l'avenir de notre modèle
familial d'exploitation à taille humaine
sont aujourd'hui en jeu alors que les
charges de nos entreprises agricoles ne
cessent de s'aggraver et il faut compter
aussi avec l'impôt
administratif qui pénalise nos
exploitations notamment les élevages en
prescrivant à l'agriculteur le respect
d'un nombre croissant de normes au nom
de la protection de l'environnement les
unes sont nécessaires bien sûr les
autres sont au contraire excessives
voire inutiles il est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre d'entreprendre une revue
générale des normes pesant sur
l'agriculture afin de les de les alléger
et de refuser de nouvelles
contraintes si nous ne parvenons pas à
donner à nos agriculteurs des conditions
plus favorables à leur activité un
mouvement de concentration sans
précédent risque de se produire pour
rejoindre les formes d'exploitation qui
ont cours en Grande-Bretagne et en
Europe du Nord avec la disparition de
très nombreuses exploitations ce n'est
pas ce que nous voulons le prix à payer
serait terrible avec une ruralité D par
sa population où se multiplieraient les
étendues en
friche alors au moment où tantant de
défi assaille le monde rural le projet
de loi que vous avez présenté qui va
affaiblir la représentation des
territoires ruraux dans de grands
cantons regroupant jusqu'à quat ou C
cantons actuels va encore aggraver les
difficultés du monde rural car il sera
moins bien
représenté nous devons également tirer
la sonnette d'alarme s'agissant à la
fois des moyens et des responsabilité de
nos collectivités territoriales nous le
savons bien la compétition des
territoires est commencée la diminution
des ressources des collectivités
territoriales la perspective de nouveaux
transferts de compétences qui ne seront
pas financièrement compensés car le lien
de confiance entre l'État et les
collectivités est aujourd'hui rompu nous
rend extrêmement inquiet pour l'avenir
de la
ruralité alors monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président pour conclure je
veux souligner que nous avons maintenant
une agriculture ouverte au vent du large
à laquelle l'Europe ne fournira plus
tous les moyens de se battre un monde
rural dont la représentation politique
va être affaiblie des collectivités
territoriales dont les ressources
propres vont être fortement amputé et se
profile une nouvelle décentralisation
qui visera davantage à alléger les
charges de l'État qu'à renforcer les
libertés locales voilà à quoi se résume
aujourd'hui l'action du gouvernement à
l'égard du monde rural ce débat n'aura
pas été inutile s'il permet de vous
convaincre de vous engager résolument
dans une autre politique plus conforme
aux attentes des territoires ruraux qui
représente 78 % du territoire national
et 22 % de notre
population merci
monsieur
merci la parole est à Madame Laurence
Rossignol
bonjour monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues d'abord merci
merci à René niikou et à Gérard baayli
pour leur travail
merci aux collègues de l'opposition qui
ont suggéré et suscité ce débat et merci
au ministre de l'Agriculture de sa
présence et il est bien d'avoir ici un
ministre qui sait que depuis déjà
longtemps monde rural et monde agricole
on cessa de se confondre confusion
pourtant présente dans de nombreuses
interventions entendu ici cet après-midi
le monde rural est mal
connu le monde rural est mal connu comme
le sont ses habitants c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'avais très modestement
pris l'initiative d'un colloque
scientifique qui s'est tenu ici au Sénat
en décembre dernier en partenariat avec
l'École normale supérieure etiner et
consacré aux représentations et
évolution des mondes ruraux et péris
urbains madame niikou y participait et
je vous ferai parvenir très
prochainement monsieur le ministre les
actes de ce colloque et ils seront bien
entendu à la disposition de l'ensemble
de nos collègues parlons d'abord de
représentation le monde rural est
souvent dans cette maison d'ailleurs
utilisé comme alibbi des conservatisme
par ceuxl même qui sont les vrais
conservateurs que n'a-t-on entendu ici
même à propos de la parité et que
n'a-t-on fait dire aux élus locaux pour
la combattre or pour être élu d'un
département de 690 communes j'ai observé
que ces fameux élus ruraux sont
infiniment moins rétrogrades et moins
réfractaires aux évolutions de la
société que ceux qui parlent en leur nom
et à leur
place alors que faut-il entendre par
monde rural où commence le rural où
s'arrête le pays urbain bien difficile à
dire dès lors qu'il n'y a plus de
territoires dans lesquels les
agriculteurs sont démographiquement
majoritaire les habitants des mondes
ruraux et P urbains sont principalement
des salariés des artisans des retraités
des jeunes scolarisés et ils ont des
problèmes de salariés de retraités et de
jeunes certains ils sont nés d'autres
ils sont venus par choix de vie d'autres
enfin il ont été contraints éloignés des
villes par la pression foncière mais
leurs aspirations sont celles de tous
les Français ils veulent des écoles des
services publi une gendarmerie ouverte
au public des accueils périscolaires
pour que les femmes puissent aller
travailler des commerces et de la
convivialité de voisinage or la promesse
d'une ville d'une vie tranquille et
heureuse n'est pas toujours tenue le
bonheur et l'espace ne suffisent
malheureusement pas à compenser
l'isolement l'abandon et le sentiment de
solitude qui Préval désormais dans
beaucoup de territoires cet isolement
est encore aggravé par le
renchérissement du prix de l'essence qui
impacte fortement les budgets des
habitants de ces territoires contint des
déplacements
quotidiens les politiques publiques qui
ont été menées au cours des 10 dernières
années n'ont pas été en phase avec la
réalité cootidienne des millions euros
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'urgence
et cette urgence s'exprime et s'est
exprimé dans les fractures démog dans
les fractures démocratiques pardon dont
témoignne l'abstention et les votes
extrémistes lors des élections
nationales alors que ce matin se réuni
comité interministéel des villes il est
indispensable de mobiliser tout autant
le gouvernement en faveur des ruraux et
pér urbains il est primordial d'agir sur
tous les sujets que j'ai cité
précédemment service public aménagement
numérique du territoire ça a été évoqué
par plusieurs collègues avant moi
économie santé et je voudrais encore
saluer l'excellent rapport de nos
collègues Fichet et Moret le
gouvernement a dors déjà pris des
mesures et l'enjeu du que le premier
ministre a démontré en mobilisant ses
ministres sur la question du temps
d'accès au servicees public et le
développement du très haut débit il faut
inventer des nouveaux services publics
il faut créatif il faut sortir des
moules que nous connaissons mais
inventer n'est pas abdiqué et il va
falloir restaurer tout ce qui a été
détruit au cours des 10 dernières années
et le constat adressé par nos collègues
par notre collègue baahi est aussi cruel
pour les territoires dont il a parlait
que pour les gouvernements de 2002 à
2012 permettez-moi enfin pour conclure
d'insister sur un aspect d'une politique
que nous pourrions engager en en faveur
des mondes ruraux et P urbains nous
débattrons prochainement de la loi
bancaire que constatons-nous
actuellement que les territoires dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui sont des
territoires qui produisent de l'épargne
mais que l'argent collecté par les
banques n'est pas réinvesti dans ces
territoires je souhaite pour ma part que
la loi oblige les banques françaises à
territorialiser l'épargne et le crédit à
l'instar de ce qui se fait avec succès
dans d'autres pays et en particulier aux
États-Unis ce serait d'ailleurs un moyen
efficace de financer aussi l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui représente plus
de 10 % du PIB et particulièrement dans
ces territoire qui est un secteur
créateur d'emploi et non délocalisable
puisque mes chers collègues nous avons
convergé sur les constats je vous
propose que nous convergions ensemble au
moment de la loi bancaire pour montrer
au TR en eururo que nous voulons
transparence et réinvestissement en leur
faveur merci Madame Rossignol la parole
est au président
Guillaume
ésent monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues la ruralité est une chance
pour la France nous l'avons toutes et
tous dit nous partageons tous les mêmes
constats essayons tout simplement de
nous dire lorsque nous parlons de
ruralité d'évoquer des choses positives
de ne pas être des pleurnicheurs mais
être des promoteurs de la ruralité parce
que tout toutes celles et ceux qui
vivent comme moi-même comme beaucoup
d'entre nous dans nos villages dans nos
communes ces milliers de femmes et
d'hommes agriculteurs artisans
commerçants président d'association font
vivre nos territoires ruraux oui la
ruralité est une chance parce que dans
la ruralité il y a des femmes et des
hommes qui croient en leur avenir qui
croient en leur vie et qui croient que
leur territoire est une chance pour
notre pays alors allons-y avançons
battons-nous défendons promouvons mais
parlons toujours de la ruralité avec des
mots
positifs le philosophe Fernand baudrel
disait la France se nomme diversité et
cette diversité c'est notre richesse
alors je suis vraiment
désolé vous me
décomte mais la ruralité a souffert elle
a beaucoup souffert
elle a été stigmatisée je prendrai deux
exemples mes chers collègues mes chers
amis la RGPP a été dévastatrice pour les
zones rurales nous l'avons tous dit nous
l'avons tous entendu et lors des
dernières élections sénatoriales
élections municipales que nous ont dit
les maires ruraux que nous ont dit les
acteurs de la diversité de la ruralité
la RGPP s'est appliqué de partout de
façon aléatoire et elle ne s'est pas
appliqué comme elle aurait dû le faire
en fonction de la situation locale elle
s'est appliqué partout ça a été une
erreur et la ruralité a souffert de même
lorsque vous évoquz lorsque nous
évoquons les territoros en terme de
gouvernance et d'élection mais le
conseiller territorial qui devait être
créé aurait diminué aurait diminué le
nombre d'élus par deux c'était dans la
loi ce que nous voulons faire c'est au
contraire maintenir le même nombre
d'élus il y aura des cantons plus grands
les mêmes que ceux que vous alliez créer
simplement il y aura deux fois plus
d'élus parce que nous pensons que la
proximité parce que le lien avec le
territoire est essentiel et voilà ce que
nous voulons faire alors pour aller le
plus vite possible je crois qu'il faut
que nous changions la perception que
nous avons du monde rural et pour être
dans le thème de notre après-midi je
vrais souligner de façon très rapide
quatre défis sur lesquels mes chers
collègues dans l'opposition comme dans
la majorité nous pouvons tous nous
retrouver sur les constats comme sur les
propositions le premier défi celui dont
on nous parle tous les jours des
personnes âgées mais comme ceux dans les
village très reculés de montagne c'est
celui de la santé allons-nous continuer
à avoir des territoires qui se vident où
il n'y a plus de permanence des soins où
il n'y a plus de médecin en zone rurale
non et le gouvernement avec le PACT de
territoire santé présenté par Madame
Touren veut combattre ce déclin et bien
combattons-le ensemble il faut
moderniser l'appareil de santé les
maternités les hôpitaux locaux les
médecins ne doivent pas quitter les les
territoires ruraux mais y être conforté
c'est ce que nous voulons faire le
deuxème défi c'est tout simplement celui
des écoles et nous avons beaucoup de
villages sans sans élèves sans écoles
mais enfin ils sont plus tristes que les
autres depuis des années chaque année
nous avions notre lot de fermeture de
classe en zone rurale et bien cette
année le gouvernement en créant les
postes et en les mettant dès cette année
affecté nous avons des ouvertures de
classe en zone rurale nous le voyons et
ça c'est un point positif le troisième
défi il a été il a été évoqué sur celui
du numérique dans le numérique nous
devons affirmer par les schémas
régionaux les schémas départementaux que
les collectivités locales depuis 5 ans 6
ans 7 ans sont à la pointe des réseaux
et à la pointe des usages et le fente
qui avait été créé avec 0 € le Fond
national du numérique et bien nous
devons tous nous bagarrer pour que
demain par la création des réseaux et
des usages que nous ferons la ruralité
soit couverte par la FTTH c'est ce que
font beaucoup de régions et beaucoup de
départements et puis évidemment
l'économie parce que l'économie combien
de commerçants combien d'artisans
combien de TPE font vivre les
territoires ruraux et l'économie sociale
et solidaire dans les zones de montagnes
dans les zones très reculés c'est les
associations d'aide à la personne qui
sont les premiers employeurs et ces
emploisl ne sont pas délocalisables
alors voilà quatre défis il aurait pu en
avoir beaucoup d'autres j'aurais pu
évidemment monsieur le ministre parler
de l'agriculture oui avec un message
d'espoir parce que vous avez sauvé la
politique agricole commune et il faut
encore aller plus loin il faut régler le
problème du foncier il faut lutter
contre l'artificialisation des terres il
faut faire en sorte que l'installation
les 5000 postes d'installation qui sont
prévu soit créé réellement parce que
jusqu'à maintenant il y en avait
beaucoup plus mais il n'y avait pas
d'installation voilà les défis et bien
sûr monsieur le ministre si vous
souhaitez que la réalité se développe
vraiment jusqu'au bout alors disons le
tout de go le loup est incompatible avec
le pastoralisme mais vous n'auriez bien
pensé que je pouvais pas ne pas en
parler alors pour conclure parce qu'il y
a des contrats urbains de cohésion
social parce qu'il y a des contrats
d'agglomération par les villes
mettons-nous d'accord mettons-nous
autour de la table pour créer la notion
de contrats ruraux de cohésion
territoriale parce que c'est comme cela
que nous y arriverons gagnant gagnant
entre l'État les collectivités locales
et les acteurs de la ruralité je vous
remercie merci monsieur
Guillaume dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Camani pour 5
minutes
bonjour monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
le monde rural est un espace en
constante évolution et et recomposition
comme le monde urbain il réagit et agit
sur les évolutions technologique et
sociétal et parfois rapide selon l'INC
les tr/4 des communes soit 95 % de la
population vivent dans l'ARE d'influence
des villes de ce fait depuis le début
des années 2000 nous assistons une
inversion de la tendance démographique
de la près-guerre l'exode rural se
transforme en exode urbain 75 % des
cantons ruraux voient leur population
progresser les Français aiment leur
espace rural et 10 millions de citadins
auraiit un PR un projet ou un désir de
vie à milieu rural la formule de
Jean-François gravier Paris et le désert
français n'est plus de mise une
dynamique des territoires s'est mise en
place depuis les années 60 et surtout
accentué avec les politiques de
décentralisation des années 80 les
inégalités régionales se sont
considérablement réduites même si les
inégalités infrarégionales et
infradépartementales restent importantes
élu du 13e département le plus rural de
France je mesure chaque jour les
difficultés qui ont généré le malaise
des territoires je mesure les défis que
nous avons à relever pour combattre les
fractures accentuées par les politiques
publiques du précédent gouvernement et
les évolutions sociétal et technologique
mon département comme beaucoup d'autres
a souffert de la stigmatisation des
territoire du désengagement de l'État
qui s'est traduit par la fermeture de
nombreux services publics ces 10
dernières années la révision générale
des politiques publique qui a été
réalisé dans une seule logique comptable
a constitué un non sens en matière
d'aménagement de l'espace national et
s'est traduite par un malaise profond
des territoires et des populations qui
vivent monsieur le ministre les défis
sont nombreux pour le nouveau
gouvernement dans ce contexte économique
et financier exceptionnellement dur nous
savons que ce contexte va peser sur les
politiques publ et les rendre plus
difficiles mais nous sommes confiants
parce que la nouvelle approche du
gouvernement a pour matrice la
reconnaissance du rôle majeur que jouent
les collectivités locales dans les
dynamiques économiques sociales et
territoriales cette nouvelle confiance
dans l'intelligence des territoires nous
permettra de mieux faire face ensemble
au nouveaux défis du monde rural au-delà
des enjeux majeurs concernant
l'agriculture et l'économie rurale les
services publics la péréquation et les
capacités financières des ctivité qui
animent les territoires ruraux je
voudrais évoquer deux thèmes qui ont
déjà été évoqués qui constituent les
défis particulièrement sensibles et
urgents pour les territoires ruraux la
démographie médicale et le Très Haut
Débit la question de la démographie
médicale a déjà été évoquée par Jean-Luc
ficher et je partage ces analyses je
voudrais simplement rappeler ici que
l'urgence est avérée et que si nous ne
prenons pas rapidement les mesures
adaptées la situation pourra devenir
irréversible pour certains territoires
ruraux comme péri urbaine d'ailleurs à
l'otgaron la démographie médicale est
telle qu'avec les départs en retraite
prévus ces CIN prochaines années 1/3 du
territoire pourrait se retrouver sans
médecin si la tendance au le
remplacement n'était pas inversée c'est
pour cette raison que le département en
partenariat avec les services de l'État
les professionnels de santé et
l'ensemble des acteurs intéressés a mis
en place une commission départemental de
la démographie médicale celle-ci a
établi un cadre pour l'accueil et
l'exercice et professionnels de santé
autour de 15 aires de santé qui
concernne tout le département dans ces
aires de santé les professionnels sont
regroupés en réseau et bénéficier de
maision de santé multisite ils doivent
établir un projet de santé qui définit
et organise les moyens d'accéder aux
soins dans chacune de ces aires de santé
Le Très Haut Débit constitue également
un enjeu majeur pour l'avenir de nos
territoires un enjeu en terme
d'attractivité de compétitivité
économique sociétale et territoriale un
enjeu à la mesure de la généralisation
de l'aduction de l'eau et de
l'électrification par le passé le
président de la République a très
clairement indiqué sa volonté de faire
du très haut débit une priorité pour
notre pays c'est à ce titre le 4e
engagement de son programme la mission
très haut débit installé par fleur pèin
a présenté récemment son projet de
feuille de route pour une stratégie
nationale du déploiement du très haut
débit cette mission ouvre des
perspectives intéressantes pour le
déploiement de cette technologie avec la
mise en perspective de l'intinction
progressive de la boucle cuivre et le
rôle prépondérant donné aux
collectivités territorial dans
l'élaboration et la mise en œuvre des
déploiements dans l'intégralité de notre
territoire y compris dans les zones
denses l'architecture assurant une
complémentarité entre le département
pour le déploiement et la région pour la
commercialisation m'a paraît aussi
novatrice et efficace les territoires
ruraux sont en attente de mesures fortes
concernant le déploiement de ces réseaux
ainsi que sur les financements qui
permettront aux collectivités d'agir des
incertitudes pèsent encore sur ce
financement et j'appelle de mes vœux un
abondement péren du Fond national
d'aménagement numérique du territoire le
monde rural n'est pas replié sur lui
même il est capable de faire face à ses
nouveaux défis et de construire un
avenir meilleur pour peu que l'État
impulse et s'engage au côté des
collectivités
territorial merci
monieur parole est à Madame Odette
hervioot monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues en tant
que dernière intervenante je voudrais
aborder un enjeu qui a souvent été
oublié encore une fois cette fois-ci
dans les nouveaux défis du monde rural
il s'agit de l'avenir des territoires
insulaires qui participe pourtant au
rayonnement maritime et au dynamisme
littoral et touristique de notre pays ce
territoire présente souvent un véritable
condensé des potentialités mais aussi
des problèmes des territoires ruraux
beaucoup d'entre nous mes chers
collègues nous aimons bien les îles
l'été pendant les vacances mais nous
sommes bien peu à connaître réellement
leurs difficultés et les combats
quotidiens des habitants et de leurs
élus pour seulement garder leur
population toujours concerné par
l'application de la loi littorale
contrainte au plan financier ne pouvant
bénéficier de sources intercommunales
suffisamment conséquente fragilisé par
la spéculation immobilière et la
disparition des rares activités
productrices nos îles métropolitaines ou
ultramarines qui elles parfois
connaissent la double insularité doit
faire face à des tensions extrêmes qui
menacent très directement leur
attractivité le caractère soutenable de
leur développement et donc tout
simplement leur survie certaines de nos
îles les plus petites autrefois habité
sont déjormais vide d'habitants pour
cell-là c'est trop tard mais pour les
plus grandes celles qui ont encore de la
population et bien l'inquiétude est
grande le retrait de la puissance
publique le départ des jeunes ménages et
les multiples inquiétudes des
entrepreneurs pourrai à plus ou moins
long terme réduire les territoires
insulaires pour reprendre la typologie
de Philippe Perrier cornet et Bertrand
Hervieux à une campagne nature ou à une
campagne cadre de vie uniquement vivante
pendant les périodes estivales et les
vacances scolaires les dangers
deapaurissement fonctionnel des îles
sont bien identifiés par les acteurs
locaux et entraînent d'ors et déjà des
ruptures majeures dans la continuité de
servicees et
d'animation infrastructure de santé
insuffisante ou inadaptée à bellî comme
Marie Galante renchérissement des coûts
de tous les approvisionnements pression
résidentielle sur des espaces
particulièrement sensible et difficulté
à assurer ce que l'on appelle la
continuité territoriale il appartient
donc monsieur le ministre à la puissance
publique de s'engager rapidement pour
encourager les dynamiques économiques et
productives notamment à travers le
maintien et l'installation de
producteurs
écoesponsables dans les secteurs de la
pêche de l'agriculture de soutenir les
entreprises et les industries innovantes
je pense particulièrement à l'exemple
des conserveries de grois dont les
produits ont été récompensés lors du
dernier siial qui génère des emplois
insulaires à l'origine de l'implantation
de nouveaux ménages avec des enfants et
le maintien donc de la population et des
écoles il faudra donc
absolument adapter nos réglementations
métropolitaine aux spécificités de ces
territoire notamment dans le domaine des
dotations de la santé du tourisme les
futures décisions nationales devront
bien évidemment s'inscrire dans le cadre
de la politique de cohésion de l'Union
mais être décliner beaucoup plus
finement dans les contrats de projet
état région tels sont les nouveaux défis
des territoires insulaires qui comme
tous les autres territoires ruraux
entendent bien monsieur le ministre
contribuer pleinement au dynamisme et
donc au redressement de notre
pays merci madame
odettevot je vais maintenant laisser la
parole à Monsieur Stéphane Lefol que je
salue ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la
forêt
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
je voudrais d'abord me féliciter de la
tenue de ce
débat tenue au sens de la qualité des
intervenants et surtout de la qualité
des arguments et en même temps tenu au
sens où je crois que parler du monde
rural n'est pas aujourd'hui inutile au
cont
je vais essayer de régler un certain
nombre de de discussions ou d'insertions
qui ont été faites au départ sur un
certain nombre de questions et puis
après je ferai en sorte de donner ce qui
peut-être l'orientation sur laquelle je
pense que le gouvernement devra
s'engager il y aura l'occasion sur la
loi sur l'égalité des territoires de
revenir ce débat est un débat ouvert de
contrôle comme on l'appelle à la demande
de l'opposition donc il s'agit pas de
discuter d'un projet d'article et de loi
mais d'essayer justement d'ouvrir un
débat sur le moyen et le long terme la
question de la ruralité vous l'avez
évoqué elle est liée bien entendu à la
question de l'agriculture et là je
voudrais répondre
rapidement à ceux qui ont pu laisser
penser que l'accord qui aurait été
trouvé sur les perspectives financières
ne serait pas à la hauteur de celui qui
aurait pu être trouvé quelques années
précédente par Jacques Chirac et
Monsieur Schroder je vais vous dire que
dans le débat qui a
porter à l'échelle européenne la
question de ces perspectives financières
le contexte d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
celui
d'hier tout le monde sait très bien que
dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui et de la
crise dans laquelle nous vivons des
déficits budgétaires de chacun des pays
des engagements des uns et des autres
bien différents aujourd'hui de ceux qui
peuvent être ceux de Monsieur Schroder
hier nous avons obtenu dans ce contexte
des perspectives financières pour
l'Europe qui correspondent aux objectifs
qu'on s'était
fixés je rappelle d'ailleurs que le
Président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozi
avait prévu avec la signature d'ailleurs
avec
d'autres Premier ministre et responsable
politique un budget où la contribution
globale des états devait baisser de 200
milliards
d'euros on était loin à ce moment-là des
160 milliards qui ont été obtenus en
engagement de dépenses on se serait
plutôt rapproché des 860 milliards qui
étaient souhaités par David
Cameron ces 100 milliards c'est lié à la
position qu'a prise le président de la
République dans ce débat et c'est lié
aussi aux objectifs qui ont été les
siens à la fois sur la politique
agricole commune sur la politique de
cohésion et contrairement à ce que j'ai
vu aussi sur la politique de croissance
car la partie consacrée à B comme on
l'appelle elle augmente de près de 30 %
sur les
investissements ça s'accompagne en même
temps du plan de croissance qui avait
prévu un certain nombre de financement
en particulier ceux de la Bui au travers
de sa
recapitalisation sujet qui va nous
intéresser d'ailleurs sur la question du
numérique sur lequel je vais revenir
tout de suite ça c'est le premier point
sur la question de la politique agricole
commune elle a un budget de manière
globale qui euh baisse dans le budget
général au niveau européen cette
tendance elle n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui elle n'est pas liée à ses
perspectives financières elle a existé
depuis les discussions qui se sont
succédé sur ces perspectives financièr
mais pour ce qui concerne notre pays ça
a été indiqué mais quand
même la position qui a été
défendue a abouti aujourd'hui à ce que
le budget dont a bénéficié la France
pour la politique agricole commune dans
les précent perspectiv financière
c'était
569 milliards d'euros nous serons dans
ces perspectives sur la base de l'accord
qui a été trouvé à
56,3 milliards
d'euros nous avons
préservé l'enjeu qui était pour nous
celui de
l'agriculture avec une baisse sur le
premier pilier certes mais qui a été
par plus d'un milliard 800 million
d'euros sur le deè
pilier pour au bout du compte aboutir à
ce que je vous disais 59,9 milliard 569
milliards sur les dernières perspectives
financières 56,3 milliards sur cell qui
viennent nous avons donc là défendu
l'ambition agricole de la France et même
l'ambition agricole de
l'EUR sur les questions posées aussi
dans le débat sur le rural la
décentralisation et les dotations
collectivité local je
rappelle que lors de la campagne
présidentielle le candidat Nicolas
Sarkozi avait fait comme proposition de
baisser les dotations globales des
collectivités locales de 10 milliards
d'euros au nom de l'effort qui devait
être fait sur la réduction des
budget c'était dans les propositions de
l'UMP et du candidat sur les dotations
je vous rappellerai si vous le souhaitez
et cherchez les programmes monsieur
l'archer vous verrez vous
trouverez chacun doit effectivement
faire des
efforts ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure ne peut pas être simplement un
effet aujourd'hui sur la dotation quand
vous-même vous étiez prêt je le répète à
baisser ces dotations de 100 ard
d'euros ces dotations ont été maintenues
sur l'année 2013 et l'objectif est de
faire en sorte que l'effort qui sera
conduit permett à chaque collectivité de
poursuivre dans la démarche de
l'investissement les moyens qu'on lui
donnera pour assurer ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure des développements et des
investissements nécessaires que ça soit
dans le monde urbain ou que soit dans le
monde
rural et sur ce débat il faudrait pas de
faux débat je le répète par rapport à
votre vos positions précédentes vous
aviez été beaucoup plus dur sur la
question des collectivités locales et en
même temps sur la réforme territoriale
je reviens rapidement sur les questions
électorales mais c'est vrai que le
conseiller territorial avec comme
objectif je me souviens d'ailleurs des
débats que vous portiez sur le
millefeuille qui qu'il fallait supprimer
sur le nombre d'élus qui étit beaucoup
trop nombreux rappelez-vous ce que vous
disiez même vous monsieur le Président
l'arché à l'époque je me souviens très
bien de ce débat donc on ne peut pas se
donner des leçons aujourd'hui et ce que
nous proposons c'est d'essayer de régler
un problème qui traîne depuis très
longtemps c'est l'équilibre au niveau
des cantons vous le savez très bien que
dans les départements en particulier si
je prends un exemple le mien il y a des
cantons qui sont à 5000 habitants et
d'autres qui sont à 35000 il était temps
de rééquilibrer les
choses avec la mesure nécessaire à la
représentation nécessaire de l'ensemble
des territoires c'est l'objectif de la
réforme qui est en discussion voilà ce
que je voulais dire par rapport à
certain nombre de d'éléments qui ont été
avancés dans le débat précédemment
maintenant je voudrais qu'on se porte
sur la question du rural je crois comme
l'a dit Guillaume très justement on est
tous attachés au monde rural et moi le
premier j'ai été élu d'une commune de
256 habitants à l'âge de 23 ans et j ai
vécu pendant plus de 35 ans je connais
parfaitement le monde rural et je sais
une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui au-delà
des débats qui vont nous animer c'est un
enjeu à la fois de territoire c'est un
enjeu de société et c'est un enjeu de
socialisation des individus sur les
territoires moi ce qui me frappe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on parle souvent
encore en France d'aménagement du
territoire alors que tout ce qui Perse
au travers du débat que nous avons eu et
alors là pour le coup qui a été partagé
par tout le monde c'est au fond
maintenant la question qui est posée de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on offre aux
habitants des territoires c'est c'est
plus simplement la question des
infrastructures qui est au cœur du débat
c'est la question que j'ai évoqué tout
de suite de la socialisation de ceux qui
habitent sur les territoires et c'est
pourquoi on débouche très vite et à
juste raison sur les questions posées en
particulier par la couverture numérique
ça consiste à se dire quoi ça consiste à
se dire qu'un territoire est perdu
lorsqu'il est coupé du reste de la
société on l'évoque dans l' bon lieu en
appelant ça des ghetos et on l'évoque
dans le rural en disant rural profond
c'est ça la grande question qui nous est
posée refuser qu'un territoire se
retrouve isolé et coupé du reste de la
société c'est ça qui est en jeu au
travers de la demande qui est faite sur
les services qui doivent être apportés
c'est ça qui est en jeu aussi sur les
questions plus larges et plus vastes de
l'accès à la culture partout où cela
doit être possible c'est pourquoi cette
question de la socialisation des
territoires
nécessite des efforts spécifiques et
vous l'avez dit sur la question du
numérique il faut un investissement et
un plan le président de la République
s'est exprimé et il faudra poursuivre
avec les objectifs de pouvoir assurer au
travers des fonds FAD qui seront
affectés cet objectif de développement
du numérique et de couverture du
territoire la Banque européenne
d'investissement et je le dis aussi aux
élus locaux elle est là aussi
recapitalisée avec un potentiel
d'emprunt pour les collectivités de près
de 60 milliards pour favoriser ses
investissements dans la couverture
numérique socialisation des territoires
c'est aussi cette question de la santé
qui a été évoqué bien sûr de service
pour les habitants qui habitent et là
aussi Marie solouren a fait des
propositions sur un plan sur la santé et
les territoires sur lesquel faudra
travailler sur lequel on devra aussi
réfléchir à la manière dont on organise
les réseaux entre ce qui ce que sont les
maisons de santé que l'ous proposons et
que nous partageons aujourd'hui en terme
d'objectif mais au-delà de la maison de
santé qui regroupe médecins infirmières
voir kiné c'est la question de la
répartition aussi de l'activité médicale
sur nos territoires entre le médecin et
l'infirmière dont il faudra discuter
c'est la question de la télémédecine et
du fait que la vraie
question posé à un médecin c'est le
diagnostic mais que il y a beaucoup
après de soins qui peuvent être rendus
et en particulier par des infirmières
donc nous avons au travers des maisons
de santé du réseau de santé qui est
proposé par Marie soltouren du rapport
avec les hôpitaux de proximité et de
l'ensemble du réseau un travail à faire
pour assurer encore là une fois de plus
la socialisation de de la santé de tous
les habitants sur tous les territoires
l'objectif d'avoir d'ici 2015 pas un
habitant d'un territoire qui soit à
moins de 30 minutes d'un lieu de santé
est un objectif que nous devons tous
partager et qu'il va falloir mettre en
œuvre je pense que ça c'est très
important je disais socialisation des
territoires sur la question de
l'éducation bien sûr et là malgré ce qui
a pu être dit créer des postes
aujourd'hui permet de maintenir des
écoles on le sait on peut se renvoyer
des arguments mais c'est une vérité
investir dans l'école aujourd'hui c'est
aussi socialiser les territoires ruraux
de demain c'est permettre à des jeunes
aujourd'hui de se former pour pouvoir
assurer leur réussite ensuite et puis
bien sûr c'est la dimension économique
du territoire et je viendrai à la
question agricole c'est la dimension
économique du territoire elle est
essentiel c'est pourquoi que toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement que ce ça le le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi que ça soit
les emplois d'avenir que ça soit bien
entendu la question du contrat de
génération j'ai veillé à chaque fois à
faire en sorte que tous les entreprises
puissent y avoir accès et en particulier
les entreprises agricoles et
agroalimentaires c'était essentiel par
rapport à cette question de l'activité
du développement économique de nos
territoires et je crois que nous avons
là aussi capacité à pouvoir engager au
travers de
l'investissement dans tous les domaines
agricooles agroalimentaire et je
présenterai dans au début du mois de
mars un projet en particulier sur la
question de la
méthanisation pour que notre pays notre
agriculture notre agroalimentaire soit
capable et je l'ai dit au travers de ce
projet sur
l'agroécologie d'assurer la performance
économique tout en assurant la
performance
écologique des processus de production
c'est un enjeu pour le monde rural je le
crois
sincèrement nous sommes donc là dans un
débat je le disais qui doit changer
aussi dans les mots qu'on emploie je
l'ai dit il faut qu'on conçoive ce débat
sur le rural avec des idées nouvelles
celle de la socialisation de tous ces
territoires et surtout on l'a dit dans
l'organisation ça m'a frappé dans le
débat le bour et les centres Bour n'ont
pas été
évoqués et je pense que pendant des
années sur le périurbain en particulier
où le rurbain c'est-à-dire la partie la
plus proche de l'urbain ou la partie la
plus proche du rural on a raisonné avec
ce qu'on a appelé tous et chacun des
élus l'a développé des lotissements qui
se sont extrêmement développés et
étendus qui ont été d'ailleurs facteur
de consommation de terre agricole je
crois qu'on devra ensemble réfléchir à
nouveau à la question de
l'urbanisation du monde rural autour des
bourgs et des centres bourgs ça c'est
une vraie question comment on a fait
pour imaginer tous nos villages comment
se fait-il que pendant des années des
dizaines d'années les gens vivaient
aussi dans les villages et qu'on a perdu
cette idée des centrebourg